are you a billionaire no I'm not
[ __ ] because you do 100 million
dollars in Revenue listen you can go eat
donuts with Schultz but I [ __ ] do
math like you ask all the right
questions our sales [ __ ] flying
hoping you weren't asking this one
you're like okay let me do the math yeah
he knows when I saw all the emails I saw
Derek's thing and I saw a podcast like
oh [ __ ] here we go he's gonna go he's
gonna go through the [ __ ] ringer I
don't think Derek did anything wrong you
know I called Derek almost immediately
to say thank you for doing this how much
money do you think you've spent total on
steroids listen
um I need a number come on what is it
enough to buy a car anymore so basically
you spend about quarter million dollars
on steroids and got a million followers
there's a lot going through my head
right now some people are like hey why
aren't you doing this I'm like listen do
you know how much is going on and what
I'm dealing with between the rocks on
steroids you know here's the thing not
all here's the thing what did you think
the rock is on steroids all right guys
Bang Bang bang I've got the liver King
here I thought a great place to start
was right now you're like in the [ __ ]
right you've got uh this massive social
media following that exploded over the
last couple of years uh allegations came
out about steroids you're like yup I did
steroids I said I didn't but I did them
uh and if you open your phone right now
people are saying all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] they're saying you're a fraud
you're a liar you're a scammer you're
name your you know thing that they could
say what does that feel like
psychologically like when you open your
phone and you're just got like the mob
coming after you what is that like
man I gotta move forward you know um
what what's going on right now I have to
deal with 100 face on right
um I know I always butcher this but
Winston Churchill said something like
you know when when you sense danger
um tackle it head on and then you cut
the consequence in half and and this has
always been my experience in life so
it's like let's not spend a minute
crying over spilled milk like what I did
was wrong you know um I immediately
apologized to my kids I've immediately
apologized to everybody you know I feel
horrible about this I probably regret
this more than anything else I've done
in my life of all the dumb stupid [ __ ] I
did this you know um but you know I feel
like a deeper obligation where you say
how's it feel like I feel like a deeper
obligation to really do my job as a CEO
of the ancestral lifestyle not just for
me to model teach and preach this
message but we need a hundred liver
Kings out there we need the guys like
Ben Greenfield we need the guys like
Andrew huberman you know that are saying
the same thing you know these nine
ancestral tenants because people are
hurting with such depth and Desperation
that this message has to get out and so
how does it feel you know um
I'm embarrassed about it I I feel like I
humiliated myself I feel like I earned
all of it I deserve all of it you know I
read the DMS and there's a lot of hate
there's also a lot of support you know
um and guys that have seen the Andrew
Schultz podcast flagrant and uh Schultz
isn't funny
no not at all
um but Kosh is funnier than Schultz oh
that guy yeah they're a good team by the
way
um I think Akash was actually really
coming for me by the way yeah he came
after me too don't worry okay good I'm
not alone and uh and so that you know
that I'm like I deserve all of it you
know I deserve all of it and I'm gonna
handle all of that you know right now
um and you know what I I just I really
did want to take a second also to tell
you thank you you know for having me on
today giving me this opportunity every
Saturday I give this Barbarian speech
and I say we do this to honor our
earliest ancestors our recent ancestors
and all of this ancestral heritage in
between so that we can be here today
enjoy the sports world and what I really
mean by that is all that in central
Heritage in between our veterans that
have protected the perimeter so that we
have the freedoms that we have today so
that we can be on this podcast so I want
to say thank you to you for your service
and protecting the perimeter for us yeah
so when you think through kind of this
entire situation one of the things that
fascinates me is uh you have multiple
phases of your life right you have uh
kind of your childhood which uh I don't
think a lot of people understand how
tough that was and some things you went
through then you had this uh what I'll
call almost like a device salesman you
know uh phase of your life then you guys
had the Dentistry phase of your life and
then you have what everyone knows now as
liver King and so maybe let's just go
through each phase and kind of uh get
some of the context I think one of the
parts uh when I told a couple of friends
that I was going to talk to you they're
like why the [ __ ] would you talk to him
I can't believe you're gonna do this but
whatever and I said look I've had people
on that uh folks love I've had people
that I've had conversations with people
absolutely [ __ ] hate BBD told me
yesterday because I've had murderers on
here and I'm like holy [ __ ] okay you
think I feel better now yeah
the same context as that yeah but yeah
but the conversation is important and
part of it is like
you can see things on the internet you
can judge people by 30 second Clips on
the internet right I've been judged by
30 second Clips on the internet and it
[ __ ] sucks at the same time you sit
down and have a conversation with
somebody you understand them it doesn't
mean you're going to agree with them
doesn't mean you're going to disagree
with everything but you at least
understand them better so like take us
back and who were you before liver King
right and what is your childhood like
where did you grow up what what exactly
was that experience yeah I was born on a
naval air base and say by Puerto Rico I
come from a military family
um my dad had been moved around station
you know from Base to Base uh he died
before I have any memory of him and so I
really predominantly grew up in San
Antonio uh I I come from a single mom
household where I have an older brother
about two years older than me I don't
know how far back you want to go but I
think um you know I'll just say
um like up until about 10 years old I
feel like I had the best you know
childhood ever my mom would take us on
ski trips I know she loved us you know
she she always complimented us she
always put her arms around us she gave
us incredible opportunities to give us
lots of freedom and she also disciplined
the [ __ ] out of us too you know you
think oh that's normal you know growing
up and then you realize you know what
your parents are just trying to do the
best job uh your parents is trying to do
the best job they can and guess what
they probably learned that from their
parents too and so um I just remember
then around 10 or so going to middle
school and um in the first day of middle
school I got my [ __ ] handed to me and
and you know I never had anything like
that happen before I mean I just
remember in you know fifth grade I was
like I was King of the mountain
everything was great you know just go to
the play I mean there's nothing to think
about or worry about you don't measure
yourself against anybody and then the
first day in middle school I mean
everybody was try I was like going to
school with adults these kids had
everybody had a mustache I had an
underarm hair you know they were twice
as big as me and they all spoke a
different language I mean they all spoke
Spanish you know and I didn't speak any
Spanish even though I was born in
Singapore Puerto Rico no I'm gonna
listen I'm not asking for any SOB
stories um but I was hearing impaired
and I had plenty of ear surgeries and I
didn't actually speak my first words for
I was in speech therapy forever and um
and so this is why I didn't actually
learn Spanish
um because they were afraid that I
wasn't going to learn English so I get I
get to my first day there um this one
guy Felix Sanchez talks to look at his
hand lets me have it almost knocks me
out first time I'd ever been you know
handed something like that but man this
just kept happening and I came home this
kept happening the same day
um and I remember the way I looked I was
a skater at the time just skateboarding
you know thinking oh this is what people
do but then I get to middle school
there's not one person dressed like me
or that looks like me or that's getting
their [ __ ] handed to them like me
um and uh and I came home and uh and I I
cried to my mom and I said I'm never
going back and before I could finish the
sentence she she didn't even listen to
the rest of the sentence she made it so
Crystal [ __ ] clear that you're going
back and that I'm not even going to
listen to anything else you have to say
that's how I remember it and so I just
remember thinking okay uh maybe tomorrow
won't be as bad maybe that's the first
day every day was like that every single
day was like that and somewhere along
the way I remember that one of my mom's
boyfriends gave us some heavy downs and
and the whole time I'd been trying to
blend in and look more like my peers and
I wore these cool Red Wing boots these
guest jeans a cool shirt
um I felt like a million bucks that it's
the first time in like a couple years
going to school I'm like oh I feel
pretty good about myself later that day
we had gym class and I come back from
gym class all my shit's gone all my
stuff's gone and I told Coach mobrick
hey all my stuff's gone and he searched
the lockers we never recovered it you
know and I ended up going home that day
in my socks and and uh somebody else's
clothes some some gym clothes
um but this continues really all through
Middle School just um I had no
self-worth to Middle School yeah I
remember looking in the mirror and I've
told the story several times so people
might hear this again I was just
completely embarrassed and ashamed of
the guy in the mirror this this brain
and this body I never stuck up for
myself not one time and I wish somebody
at least told me hey man you gotta at
least fight back you gotta at least take
this why do you think you didn't fight
back was it something where you thought
you couldn't you thought it's not worth
it what do you think you know from day
one
saw how Giant and Powerful everybody was
and then every day there's bloody fist
fights at my school and a teacher
wouldn't dare break that [ __ ] up because
the teacher gets retaliated uh on and so
um the gym teachers would have to come
from five minutes away and there was it
was the most violent thing I mean
I I've never seen anything like that
before so the kids are just [ __ ]
going at it going at it at school oh
yeah yeah I mean these are the days you
could wear steel toes to school
um kids carry little 380 guns I mean
there were weapons everywhere there were
no metal detectors there was nothing
like this
um but they were just bloody ass fights
and so something got imprinted up here
like you don't want any part of that and
so um like I said I don't know exactly
why I just know like I actually didn't
have it in me I'm sure I always did but
I believed I don't even have it in me to
push back you know so I just retreated
and retreated and I took the punches and
I took the push downs and um you know I
never used the restroom because that's
where [ __ ] got you know the worst so
I always remember holding that [ __ ] all
day long
um and and then of course like you
wouldn't have a sip of water in school
you know because you're not gonna make
it any worse so this is what happened
most of my middle school you know it was
just like I just felt inadequate like I
knew I knew that the world would be a
better without me what about your
relationship with your brother right so
I grew up in a family of five boys and
one of the things our parents always
told us was like Hey you five are gonna
fight all the time at home we know that
there's no stopping that uh but when you
guys leave here is you guys versus the
world right and I remember uh
specifically one situation where one of
my brothers uh he got his finger broken
on the bus they used to play this stupid
game where uh they would basically turn
around on the seats and they would like
slap at each other's hands yeah and he
ended up breaking his finger pretty bad
and we we got home from uh the bus and
you know he walks home he's like hey Mom
looking like his fingers like literally
you know at an angle and uh I remember
talking to my parents and they were like
immediately what'd you do I was like
well you know I wasn't involved right
like I don't get me in trouble over this
and they're like no that's the problem
was you were there with your brother and
something happened but like what did you
do did you stand up for me you have his
back whatever I remember that moment
vividly because it just reinforced this
idea of uh sometimes you just gotta find
who are the people who are gonna you
know you could surround yourself with
that always have your back regardless of
what happens in the world so you talked
a little bit about your mom but what
about your brother and kind of what was
your relationship like him he was two
grades above me so I was in sixth grade
he was in eighth grade um and there was
no discussion about anything that
happened at school when I came home you
know there was no message for my mom you
better [ __ ] be there from them there
was no message from my mom hey how you
doing
was your second day any better than the
first there was none of that I mean from
the first day she made it really clear
I'm not hearing any of this so there was
no more of this shared with her and so
and her defense there was no discussion
with my with my brother you better
[ __ ] watch over him yeah
um and so my my brother was I have no
recollection whatsoever my brother's
standing up for that for me or being
there for me you know I learned these
values later um I did end up getting
strong and when I got strong I'm like
um I became the big brother and there
you know people would come after my big
brother and then Mark would run to me
saying hey man I need your help and I
loved being able to help him the tables
got turned you know from working out so
I wish I could tell you that my brother
was there for me my brother wasn't there
for me how old uh did you start uh
working out I was around eight or nine
at the time yeah and what and when you
first start like are you just doing
push-ups and sit-ups like what is that
my mom's boyfriend at the time gave us
his old bench yeah I don't know if
there's any irony in this but he was a
pharmacist a big [ __ ] pharmacist like
six four really big Michael gleinsner I
don't know all this might be edited out
but um he gave me this old bench that
was falling apart Rusty as [ __ ] and I
went to town on bench press curls um I
started getting all the muscle magazines
I would read the exercises I could do I
would it was one of those old ones that
had like the leg extensions of the curls
out there I wish I was doing power
cleans and and squats and and stuff like
that but that's the kind of bench I had
that's kind of working out I was doing I
really wasn't doing push-ups but I
remember
um I did have some self-worth back home
because some of the other kids up the
street they couldn't bench nearly what I
could bench
um and and I knew that I was getting
strong but I also knew at school any
retaliation for me any standing up for
me you got 30 other people that are
coming and that's another thing that
happened at school that I think I left
out the fights would happen and and if
the tables got turned for a second you
got 20 other people jumping in that are
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you and I
just remember thinking man I don't want
any of this was the school aware of this
stuff happening were they trying to stop
it or it was just a situation we're like
yo this happens at our school we do the
best we can but like these kids are just
gonna beat each other out I think both
uh I mean happen every day it was part
of the culture and and I remember that's
crazy right like to send your kids to
school and if you're aware that there's
a chance that they're going to get in an
absolute you know face ripping fight
every day you're kind of like you know
am I doing my kid a disservice to some
degree yeah well that's for sure what
happened at my school and um there was a
history teacher who tried to break up a
fight and later that day he got the [ __ ]
handed to him by the way the kids are
beating up the teachers yeah and the
teachers know not to break up the fights
yeah the the gym guys have to come over
and then nobody's messing with Coach
Boberg this guy looked like a lineman
for an NFL team um but that that's what
happened I mean and and I think that's
part of the concern that the I was
terrified you know like could that could
that happen to me yeah and so again I
know how much uh there's a great there's
a great example this guy Chuck came to
school another white kid like me way
bigger than me but still he came to
school and I thought I'm gonna make a
friend I could do this and I kind of
made a friend
um but he starts getting in these fights
and they're bloody as [ __ ] and he's
doing a pretty good job actually these
fights
um we start making a friendship but he
fought back enough times they took him
in and then it was him against me and
then he picked a fight with me this
sounds almost identical to uh like
prison culture right where basically
people uh set up alliances with each
other uh and some of it is literally
based on race language Creed you know
what whatever the the kind of uh way
that the population cuts themselves uh
and then it is almost the most
animalistic thing in the world of just
like who has physical dominance over
other people it's pretty animalistic and
um yeah I I I again like I mean I tell
my kids all the time jokingly you know
you guys go to jail you better [ __ ]
pick a fight on the first day you know
and again like I wish I wish God damn I
wish somebody just told me I wish
somebody told me man this is what's
going to happen to you yeah I wish
somebody just said and when it does
you're gonna get your [ __ ] [ __ ]
handed to you you're gonna get bloody
um but but you're gonna be able to push
back and you're strong and you'll get
through it man and it's going to happen
five or six times but you'll get through
it and they'll take you in
um but nobody told me that um and you
know what I just also want to make it
clear that I know we're still talking
about this phase you don't hear about
all my phases but um I couldn't be more
grateful for for this was my first true
rite of passage in life and I had to
figure this out and I had a little bit
of help along the way one of my one of
my friends mom's
um knew about someone who challenged me
to a fight and I said why would I do
this I'm not getting into a fight long
story short she mentors me and says
you're strong you got to get into this
fight she drives me to the fight she
drove you to the fight she drove into
the fight to fight this guy this kid had
to get in a fight in front of his gang
to be initiated into the gang and so
this kid Chris with like a bunch of
people
um and and so
um anyways what is the past I don't know
if you want to hear the details of the
fight but um I I found out how strong I
was that day and it had to take all
these [ __ ] years to figure that out
it it took her saying hey you're strong
you can do this
um her son Justin's like yeah man you
could do this my brother was around at
that time my brother's like yeah man you
could do this too like you guys have no
[ __ ] idea you have no idea because I
knew I couldn't do it
um but you know what's also cool about
skateboarding is like you drop it on a
15-foot ramp with vert enough times and
you just fall and you fall I mean
imagine throwing yourself off a 15-foot
building you know and again you know
fall 15 complete feet but you take
enough spills you're like oh I'm gonna
be okay I'm gonna be okay enough
experience says
um I can develop High courage and one
day I can face danger and I'm gonna be
okay and what ends up happening you know
through through that fight is I realized
like I actually am strong like I looked
pretty strong I actually was strong I
figured out that I was strong and um and
I actually let him go I I I had him
pinned on the ground and I could have
done what I needed to do to him and uh
and you know what maybe it's because I
didn't have the experience maybe it's
because um I looked in his eyes and I
saw how pathetic and scared he was and I
saw myself in his eyes and I couldn't
strike him
um sometimes I think [ __ ] like I really
regret that like yeah that could have
changed everything for me I think it
could have but a lot of people uh have
told me man I respect you so much more
for not doing that but again I think
this is the rite of passage for me um I
wouldn't wish this on anybody but I
ended up figuring it out and I ended up
I was getting stronger the whole time
but man this happened I got this fight
and I doubled down on working out I mean
if you think about this I'm some kid at
home I'm working out once a day but now
I'm working out twice a day and now I'm
really learning you know doing
everything in the magazines Arnold
Schwarzenegger was my hero you know
anything he would post the magazines I
was doing I had all his posters
everywhere
um and so that that I think would unless
you want to get into it more would
summarize my 10 to 14 15 year olds
what's interesting to me is a lot of the
things you're describing still happen
today in schools but now it feels like
uh maybe society's changed maybe the way
that people uh uh young kids because
social media or what I don't know what
it is but this the story that maybe we
would have heard 20 30 years ago right
was uh if you're a young kid and you're
getting your ass kicked at school if
you're getting bullied if you're
whatever you basically change schools
you stand up for yourself you work out
you you do something to try to impact
the situation and it usually was the
release of working out or uh building a
friendship with another bully that could
you know back you up or whatever now I
think a big fear of parents and and many
people in society is like that kid who's
getting bullied goes and gets a [ __ ]
gun and shows up to school and just
starts shooting people I want to make a
comment about that because um I had my
list and this is I think when Jordan
talks about you know the the young men
today that are hurting and hating and
suffering and struggling the most
um when you don't have self-respect for
yourself which would be when you don't
have any respect from your peers this is
me
um there's enough time that goes by
where you start to become dangerous to
society because you can get a gun all
the kids at my my school had guns so I
knew I could get a gun and so I kept a
list of of the guys that I was going to
take care of when I could get myself a
gun now that's how much I hated what was
going on it was like it was it was
either myself I thought about that
myself taking my own life or or figuring
out a way to get them and and so um and
do you think that's just like a human
nature thing right is that like you
eventually reach a breaking point where
you're just like these people have been
[ __ ] with me for so long I have to do
something whether it's fight them with
my fist whether it's shoot them or
whatever like like why is it that even
then when people had guns at school and
and it wasn't uh kind of the the
environment it is today
the the response like the the human
nature response was exactly identical to
what it seems like young kids today are
going through
I I think that um nothing in life really
stands still you know everything's
evolving and I think that's the
evolution of what happens you know again
an expert like Jordan Peterson can tell
you like the trajectory of that
Evolution
um I I don't know why all I knew is like
okay the the hurt and the hate that I
had
um that this can't continue forever I
mean I I did this for years and so my 15
year old actually between 10 and 15. I
was in Middle School so um I think I was
in seventh grade so maybe I was like 12
or something like that my bus driver
committed suicide and and at that time I
knew okay this is actually possible now
I could think about this and the kids
were talking about like the bus driver
committed suicide and like word spread
throughout the kids there were so many
fights out on a bus
um that he would have to stop the bus
you know let's stop fighting he would
have to try and uh he was a big guy he
was a really big guy
um he could break up fights and then one
fight he had a lot of trouble breaking
up and I don't even remember exactly
what he did
um but I think he got suspended and then
the next day the bust income and then
later that day at school they announced
dead and they said hey we're here to
talk about it you know kind of deal I'm
like oh my God like that this can
actually happen I've never heard of this
ever before in my life but but I had
heard of it then and so I just think
that um that there's this trajectory
like there's only so much of that you
could take either for yourself you know
you got to do something you know for
yourself but do anything for yourself is
like I'm gonna take care of these guys
you know and I think that that's an
issue like with violence it's like
people can get a gun today people can
drive a car today you know
um yeah they can use any any tool that
is a part of everyday life and use it as
a weapon if they so choose or if that's
what their intentions are yeah so I want
to make make this point about the Silver
Lining is um you know how much hate that
I've received from the beginning of
social media which is at least 10x right
now but but when I when I see this it's
shocking that people hated you at all at
any point okay okay I'm like well is he
serious
um but the thing is I know how that
feels you know like I know exactly how
that feels and you know whenever you
read a word or or a text or you hear the
words like it's up to your brain to
assign meaning to it and and so since
the Inception of liver King whenever I
I've got any of those hate messages I'm
like I know exactly how this person
feels this was me and this person's
hurting the most and this person is
actually why I have this why in the
world because people are hurting at
these desperate rates and I know the
solution to get them better and so I got
to find a way to connect with them you
know because I'm if you see some of
these messages like
um you might think I can't believe you
didn't retaliate with words you know
like you're and I'm like and I I can't
tell you how many times I've written
back I know how this feels I know
exactly how this feels and let me tell
you I I agree some of what what you're
saying is true especially right now the
message I'm getting is I know exactly
how this feels um what I did was wrong I
own this I am sorry to you and I'm going
to do everything I I can do to be better
please continue to engage with my
content or some sort of ancestral living
so that you can get better too A lot of
that is uh understanding of the
situation but a lot of it's maturity as
well right if if you were getting those
messages at 21 I don't know you know you
know better than I do but like would you
be responding the same way you think oh
man you know
once I finally got strong after I got
that fight and I got strong and I
realized what I was capable of this is
why I have an obligation now to to do
whatever I can to do good because I did
a lot of not good things for those
what's the worst thing you ever did well
they're all fights you know they're all
fights and um but I mean there there
would be guys that like
I just I I handed it to him yeah you
know um so I mean but but I mean I never
like
send someone to the hospital yeah did
you have like almost a Redemption Arc to
some degree yes where basically hey I
used to get my [ __ ] you know beat up and
now all of a sudden I'm doing the
beatings yeah you know there's these
movies do you remember boys in the hood
or Minister Society yeah these raised me
you know and and so the minute I got
strong Classics yeah I mean really and
this is what I realized look you don't
talk [ __ ] about your mom like this is
when I started to learn I think a lot of
really valuable experiences actually
um and and I think that this is one one
of the movies you know like somebody
looked and they're like hey let's take
it outside and I would do that all the
time be like hey man you got a problem
yeah let's take it outside and and you
know most of the time nobody wanted to
take it outside and when we would take
it outside this was an opportunity like
okay now I'm actually pretty good at
this I'm fascinated by the uh
bifurcation of society because there's a
whole bunch of people who think we'd be
better off if that was still the way
that things worked right was basically
uh
forget what words you put on the
internet right uh if you wouldn't say it
to somebody in person into their face
don't say it online type situation yeah
and I think it's Mike Tyson's like hey
people forgot they get punched in the
[ __ ] face yeah right and people do
this all the time too in crowds you know
because you would think I would get a
lot of hate in public I don't get hate
in public no you know it's I can't
believe how incredible people are and
then and then it reminds me
um you got a vocal minority here you
know that are being really vocal um
because we get on public and people are
amazing and you can feel their Spirit
energy in this connection every once in
a while you hear somebody mouth
something off and it's in a crowd and
you're usually going opposite directions
um and I would never do anything to them
yeah like you know let them have it you
know and I've told my kids um you guys
know how much hate we're gonna get right
now and and we've not been out and about
yesterday we were out and about and just
trying to go onto the beach to go
swimming as a family
um yesterday by the way my son Striker
beat me in a race that's the first time
he's just [ __ ] smoked me physically
athletically
um
um but uh there was so much love there
was so much love and and again I I'm
expecting it I'm expecting to hear it
and again I'm gonna say I deserve it all
yeah I own all of it you know so bring
it on I want them to be prepared but
it's really interesting and and I do
believe that we would be far better off
as a society say it to if you're not
going to say it to their face what do
you think you're doing you know what
what does it actually give you to do
this anonymously on the internet I'm not
sure what that accomplishes
um but but I do know how it feels to
hurt and to hate your life that badly
and maybe it makes them feel good for
about a second but obviously nobody's
actually getting to the root issue when
they do that yeah uh I think anyone who
has any size following on the internet
obviously has uh uh people who love them
people who hate them and everyone in
between
um but when you start to think about it
as wow you really got to be in a bad
place to say some of the things that are
said online uh there is this like
compassion almost right and uh it's hard
to have that conversation with people
who don't have a big online following
because they don't they haven't seen it
they haven't seen how I think vile and
just disrespectful uh even sometimes
dangerous people can be right if you
gotta I don't know maybe more than 100
000 followers on the internet there's
you do it long enough you're gonna get a
death threat you're gonna get you know
what whatever the the worst thing you
could think people send us our my
address you know they'll they'll send
the address I'm coming my address you
know my personal address uh what do you
do in that situation when somebody says
that you just you just ignore it or you
no no no no I mean I try to no we don't
we listen we got a pack of Dobermans at
the house and we have an arsenal of guns
are out of control you know um I do
believe this is my responsibility to to
be able to fight provide and protect my
family
um so listen I'm not saying hey come but
if you come Uninvited this is this
doesn't end well
um I want to say I think that maturity
started way way before
um being able to connect and know what
it feels like to hurt and hate your life
because
um this whole thing started my business
is really as an evolutionary Hunter as
an entrepreneur started because my kids
were sick because I couldn't breathe and
and what does that what does that mean
they couldn't breathe um they were going
to the hospital because they were
allergic to things and they would choke
up they would have anaphylactic shock
and they would turn blue they were good
for the first time I haven't said that's
gonna be scary oh yeah I mean but it
keeps happening and every time it's
scary and every time you think oh my God
I could lose but what if my kid wasn't
here what if we didn't have an EpiPen
what if we didn't have all this stuff
figured out there's only so much of that
you take we figured it out through
ancestral living ancestral living was
our savior you know this is why we so
deeply believe in this this is why I'll
never stop this fight even if it's not
liver King that leads its charge like
I'm going to make sure there's a hundred
other CEOs of the ancestral lifestyle
that are preaching that liver is King I
know what that is like to go through
that kind of Health crisis and I've
always said what kind of piece of [ __ ]
am I going to be if I don't spread this
message if I don't make this my why in
the world so what ends up happening is
um I started a company and the the whole
purpose of this company was to advance
ancestral living and we also sold some
notes-to-tail nourishment liver bone
marrow heart all this kind of stuff and
a lot of customers would come because
they had a health issue and what ends up
happening invariably you start to get
some negative reviews hey I bought this
I thought it was going to work for this
it didn't work and and they're mad and I
didn't have the money to spend on it and
I think all the reviews are fake and
[ __ ] and all this stuff and I just
start thinking oh my God like you're
just like my boys you know I got to
figure out a way to connect with you
before I even responded to them I mean I
handled everything in my companies right
um and I knew I know what it feels like
to go to the doctor and the doctor
doesn't listen to at all because you're
saying the same story you know you've
been five or six doctors they don't want
to hear it anymore you you're telling
your friends they don't want to hear it
anymore so every customer that came to
me you know like I I know what it feels
like and so I'm going to connect with
you we're going to talk and and before I
would even write an email back I would
always give them a refund and I always
knew I the meaning I signed is they're
not really hurting and they're not
hating me right they came to me because
they were suffering and we got to figure
out a way to get them better and
oftentimes it doesn't have to do with a
supplement at all somebody has high
blood pressure maybe they just need to
get midday Sun maybe they just need to
take off their shoes and connect with
the Earth they need to deepen a
parasympathetic Bond you need to put
down the damn phone and hold the hand of
somebody that you love and take in the
sunset you know and so when you get to
nurture them along with these nine
ancestral tenants and they see there's
no Financial incentive for you and then
you say I think we got the initial
product suggestion wrong in the first
place let me buy you the next couple of
months on the house and we'll just see
how you feel do that so I I think where
this initially came from was
um there was a connection my kids were
hurting I knew that we were and I was
mad I was mad like every [ __ ] who we
met at all the doctors you're telling me
that all we can do is give them this
EpiPen in their leg when they can't
breathe you know you're telling me and
really even if it wasn't like an acute
situation you could listen to them and
they weren't breathing very good you
know even in their sleep it's like there
was wheezing and so I was bad and so I
think that's where I started to connect
with this whole philosophy is
um I understand that hurt and hate and
they came to us because they were
suffering with something they're still
suffering with something and I do
believe that the path forward is
ancestral living I got to be able to
guide you and Coach you and and once you
can see some benefit and value and
invariably when you do that this is the
most loyal customer on Earth just
because you did the right thing and so I
wish it maybe it's a combination of
maturity and experience but I've been
through all that you know the 10 to 15
year old self I've been through that I
hated my life I know what that feels
like um when my kids couldn't breathe
and they're going to the hospital
I hated my life again because it's like
I'm doing this to them yeah one of the
arches of life is that like you're a kid
and then you become a parent you
mentioned earlier that your father
passed away before you really ever
experienced uh or had any memories with
him how did he pass away or how do you
think that situation impacted uh both in
your kind of adolescence but then also
when you became a father
you know I don't know about my
adolescence you know um
I have nothing to compare it to but uh
as a father like you know what I have an
obligation to be here I I know ancestral
living these These are the principles
and philosophies that will enable me to
be healthy to do my job as a dad I need
to be here as a dad it's one of the
reasons that we do a five-day water only
fast once a quarter I hate doing that
it's have you ever done it huh no I one
time didn't eat food for 24 hours I
thought I was a gangster
I was like hell yeah yeah some people
were like and I did five days with her
house like all right yeah well every
Wednesday and Sunday I do a 24 hour
water only fast hold on every Wednesday
and Sunday yeah for 24 hours you don't
eat that's right so you only eat five
days out of the week well if you think
about it on Tuesday I had dinner so then
all I have to do is get breakfast and
lunch on Wednesday uh resume dinner got
it yeah and so you end up having 24
hours it's like a busy day basically it
is yeah
um but people are so used to just
snacking and feeding non-stop that they
think if they're gonna skip skip a meal
and a lot of people call if I skipped a
meal and I'm fasting I don't really call
24 hours fasting even but this is the
reason why that to me is effortless but
to do a five day water only fast is not
easy and and then I would say on day two
or three you know the letter queen and I
are like we'll go on a walk we're all
there and we're like oh my God you feel
like [ __ ] yeah I feel like oh God why do
we do this you know how I do this is
because I grew up without a dent and
I'll be damned if there's something I
can do about it to be there for my guys
what happens to your body when you go
through the five day fast like what
what's going on physiologically
physiologically like the benefits or
yeah yeah like what what why do people
say hey it's good for you to do or
whatever yeah have you ever heard of
apoptosis no um you sound like a like a
Wikipedia entry right now no way no way
what is that so there's a few benefits
and I'll explain some of them so there's
apoptosis autophagy metabolic
flexibility something called
mitochondrial biogenesis like
um apoptosis is when it's a natural
process that that we would go through
um our early ancestors with a feast and
famine cycle when you're not eating
apoptosis is the natural process where
the cell self a sick cell will
self-destruct okay and today we're
always feeding ourselves we don't have
that natural process that should be
ongoing which can lead to some mutations
in chronic health issues so apoptosis is
a natural process that should be
happening when we don't eat for a few
days so and again this was something
naturally that would happen autophagy is
like a
cellular house cleaning it's like kind
of the garbage in the cell you know that
should be cleaned out which again
doesn't happen very often unless we fast
metabolic flexibility you might know is
like um if you're not eating for a while
the then beta oxidation or living off a
keystone ketones in fat instead of being
a sugar burner like it allows you to be
a lot more metabolically flexible and
then lastly um mitochondrial biogenesis
is like it's all about energy production
right and you're not eating anything and
so now your body starts to say oh my God
he's not eating anything there's a whole
lot of other things that that are going
on like are something called the reverse
thyroid goes through the roof it starts
to slow you down and then you start to
be able to produce more mitochondria to
try and give you more energy so I'll
tell you what ends up happening after a
five-day fast like again the five day
fast is horrible I think there's a lot
of incredible longevity benefits that
happen but almost immediately afterwards
the performance benefits are through the
roof like your brain you ever seen the
movie Limitless yeah it's like I mean
I've never had that pill but it's like
that for a while you know and so it
feels so good I'm like well I'm gonna do
this every quarter again that week is
hard but after a couple of days of
recovering man you feel incredible so
there's a lot of benefits
um even if you take the benefits out I
think what's most important what reason
why we do it is
um modern day primitive cultures do it
not intentionally because they're going
on hunts and they're not they're not
getting the kill our early ancestors
always had these feast and famine Cycles
so it's to honor the struggle of our
early ancestors right and it's to honor
these um nine ancestral tenants that
always enabled us for millions of years
to express robust Health we stopped
doing this you work out while you're
doing it not really I mean we'll go on
long walks yeah but uh yeah you try
working out on so on day one I do what's
called a simulated failed hunt okay and
I think it's pretty natural to what
early ancestors would have gone through
you would have gone on a hunt you would
have failed it you deplete any glycogen
in your body I think the metabolic
flexibility benefits will come I think
all the benefits come on sooner if you
can do the failed hunt so yeah like what
do you do for a failed hunt you just go
run around in the woods Kinda Yeah I
mean it's uh something kind of intense
in a shorter time domain to simulate a
failed hunt maybe it's just taking like
a heavy d-ball uh um which is like uh uh
like a maybe a hundred pound ball or
something and doing a whole bunch of
ball cleans over the shoulder for 10-15
minutes running a visible exertion to
get your energy up and sweat a little
bit and then basically say hey look I
did some physical activity uh but I
didn't get any food at the end of it
right right and then I would say day two
three and four
like you don't really have a whole lot
like even if you wanted to man you could
try and put yourself in the gym and it's
just not really working out I might do a
couple of push-ups here and there to try
and get a little bit of energy but then
on day five when you're breaking the
fast I'll do a simulated successful hunt
and then I'll carry the carcass back and
and again I think that this is all
evolutionarily consistent with what our
early ancestors would have gone through
um and it feels good you know like if
you think about early ancestors one day
wouldn't have just woken up after five
or six days of not eating and not had to
put forth any effort and then they get
to eat you know like you would have to
put forth some effort yeah but you just
pop in a Pop-Tart in the uh in a toaster
I'm actually as good as [ __ ]
so easy yeah I don't know I don't know
if those guys tried to make me eat
donuts the other day I saw Shoals had
the donut g day you know what I call
that the subprimal plate you know and
when I look at that plate and I look at
what I get eat back home the primal
foods that I get there's nothing more
delicious than the primal foods that I
get to eat and we are spoiled we have
liver King Chef Lionel that makes these
incredible meals for us like there's
nothing you could put in front like when
I see that plate I'm like it looks
really interesting right like the way
that they try to make bright colors the
whole thing wrinkles I mean the way that
they're Pat all of it I'm like oh they
got you and it's crazy that people are
buying what they're selling
um but uh yeah you say popped I don't
know what the hell but so what you live
in uh in Texas right right all right uh
what I understood there's a couple
things in uh uh emails and and uh a
number of the messages I watched a
number of videos there's probably more
research that I've done for for a
conversation in a while because I'm like
oh [ __ ] I don't know anything about this
let's go get educated
um and I'm just gonna throw out things
that surprised me or uh were interesting
to me as I kind of watched these the
first is that you live on a pretty big
plot of land in Texas and uh and one of
the emails that you sent uh to I guess
it was a doctor right where you're
asking for uh medical advice and help
and coaching and all this stuff yeah uh
you talked about everyone comes to you
you don't go to an office or what is
like the the work uh setup that you've
got going on and are people just showing
up to your house to like do work yeah
this is really interesting you ask um I
know we probably won't say exactly every
phase
um we've covered the 10 to 15 year old
phase uh from 20 to 30 what was the
corporate phase okay so you wore suit
and tie I went to like a corporate
office oh well for I wore a suit and tie
for about five years okay and then I
wore scrubs for maybe like the next five
years and I didn't see my kids yeah um
my wife didn't see our kids
um and and so she put her foot down she
goes Hey listen I'm I'm done we're both
providing for the family I'm not
caretaking I'm not nurturing them I'm
not nourishing them I'm done as a
professional this is on you and I'm like
the thing well actually at the time I
wasn't like thank god
um actually at the time I was like you
know trying to twister hey just a little
longer just a little longer
um you guys were making like decent
money or it was a struggle what was it
like 20 to 30. yeah when we first met um
I was making about a quarter of a
million she was making about a quarter
of a million when we met we were making
about half a million a year and this was
20 years ago so it was pretty decent
money you're both we we did good what
kind of car were you driving
oh god
um I was I was writing uh I was riding a
Range Rover but but you were [ __ ]
ball let me tell you why it's come on
let me tell you what's the fastest way
to figure out come on let me tell you
why why this is funny because I I just
met my wife's snowboarding yeah she's a
she's living in New York I'm in Houston
and uh and I'm living in like this
really a big house all right uh it's
like a three-story house widening I mean
by yourself by myself and I go listen I
go pick her up from the airport we had
met snowboard she goes back home I go
back home and then she comes to visit me
and I'm thinking if she comes to visit
me I'm gonna pick her up in my Range
Rover I'm taking her back to my Mansion
it's done it's done right anyways
um [ __ ] ancestors I got a goddamn modern
cave over here
so this is what I think this is what I
think and then um after a couple of
weeks things are going really really
well and we get engaged really quickly
we get married right but but she's got
to move to Texas I said hey what kind of
car do you want and she goes a car I
don't know I mean I'll just take the
same thing that you have
and I'm like do you do you even know
what I have do you know what that and
here's the thing it didn't impress her
at all because she had no idea so she
ends up having to get one too she goes I
want what you have in blue okay so
um what what ends up happening after so
you had two Range Rovers so you're
definitely bawling but yeah well we were
doing good we were doing good
um but I would say um then the
evolutionary Hunter entrepreneur side
came out I'm almost uh not too long
after we got married and what so this is
the Dentistry uh kind of is it a network
like what was this because it is
fascinating to me that like uh you were
doing pretty well uh by all measurements
in Corporate America and and things like
that you all get together uh she's a uh
dentist yeah and then you guys build a
business but
um one of the things uh that I've taken
away I've talked to a lot of different
people I am very fortunate I got a lot
of friends that have built massive
online followings whether it's podcasts
or emails or [ __ ] social media
whatever these people are not dumb right
and it's easy to look it's like oh look
at this idiot you know he's just taking
photos look at this woman she's just
take a photo whatever but like these
people understand something and I think
seeing that you had already built
another business that had been quite
successful is you know a data point of
like you guys understood how business
works and so walk us through just like
what was that business and how exactly
did it work yeah so she didn't want to
work for anybody anymore and I said cool
because you know like I know I'm pretty
good at what I do and the kind of
commissions I was getting was such a
tiny fraction of the sales I'm like hold
on a second I'm I'm doing 30 million in
sales and I'm getting I'm getting this
yeah what were you selling uh medical
devices got it okay and um and so I said
hey do you want to do this business
she's like yeah let's do the business um
I want nothing to do with it uh but I
want my own practice uh I'll be the
dentist you do the business stuff so we
bought this practice for about half a
million and then I started figuring out
okay
um no no no no no no no no how do you
structure the deal you remember
um we just got a loan from A bank it's
like a seven year and here's the thing
like we had never had a note so big in
our lives yeah like we hold holy [ __ ] we
got to pay seven thousand dollars a
month you know what I'm saying
um we had never done anything like that
but gotta sell the Range Rover
everything was leveraged we didn't know
any different I mean everything and what
ends up happening is I'm like okay now
we got to make money because now we got
to pay that back
um and and so I started looking at um
the model of the business and I just
spent like a couple days there and I'm
saying they're referring all these
Patients Out to the oral surgeon the
periodontist the Imaging Center the lab
and you sit there for a day like what
the hell are we doing why are we not
doing all of this so somebody comes into
the dentist the dentist is essentially
like the primary care of the the uh
mouth if you will and there's work
that's being done there people are
paying or the insurance companies paying
for it but you're saying then oh you
need additional work so you would refer
it out and in the Legacy model do you
get a referral fee for them no so it's
just like hey I'm sending you to my
friend because they can do the oral
surgery you might get a Christmas basket
you might get tickets to go watch a game
yeah this is what would happen and and
and so you know who who really suffered
was the patient because the patient
comes back and the radiographs aren't
there or they're [ __ ] up oh hey I'm
really sorry gotta go back to the
Imaging Center
um the the crown or whatever product you
get back from the data lab that's [ __ ]
up all didn't fit sorry come back next
week go back to the dental lab and all
this stuff we're like for continuity of
care and this makes sense why don't we
start bringing this all Under One Roof
got it and and so
um we doubled so that practice was doing
about four or five hundred thousand
dollars a year when we bought it we did
1.2 within the next year and then 2.4
the next year and then almost 5 million
a year after that I'm like you know what
we're pretty good at this you know and
the growth that's happening there is uh
you're growing like the primary care
business or you're bringing in these
other uh components and now it's all
that Revenue we vertically integrated
the whole thing yeah so now she has
every specialist in dentistry working
underneath her we had an Imaging Center
in our same building we bought the real
estate we we started a dental lab and so
not only are we benefiting from our own
we're referring to ourselves but now
we're getting other places to refer to
us got it as well
um and so that started to kick ass
um
what was it called like ancestry
Dentistry
oh I win I wish um if I had the
opportunity right now to rename it it
would have been called strong job strong
job and that actually is a company that
we're launching in in the near future
what's fascinating though is uh I
actually didn't know this I was reading
the book uh James Nester uh wrote a book
called uh breath or breathe and
um you know somebody recommended to me
and and I knew it was going to be a good
book because literally I was here
somebody was on the podcast I had the
book we got in the elevator and he was
like that was that book was stupid it
wasn't very helpful to me like it's you
know just breathe right and we got in
the elevator there's a dude who saw the
book and he was like I was literally
just doing breathing exercises the most
amazing book when I was like all right I
gotta read this thing and in the book
they talk about how actually Savages
have better teeth than the Civilized
populations and their whole thing was
you know soft foods like all these
things I'm sure that you've talked about
and it just blew my mind
civilized people were actually [ __ ] up
more than just people who live naturally
you go see modern day program culture
tribes their oral health their dental
health is almost Flawless and this is
the thing we believe we're sold this
bill of goods if you brush and floss
this is the oral hygiene hypothesis if
you brush and floss you're not going to
get cavities well our early ancestors
didn't brush didn't floss and they don't
get cavities modern day primitive
culture tribes we've been to the Amazon
Africa and Mongolia we've seen six or
seven different tribes they don't brush
they don't floss they don't get cavities
it comes down really to about two or
three things one is um the nutrition
right so you have this is why liver is
King right you need the fat soluble
system vitamin A d k and some e so you
need to have that fat soluble system but
you also need to have the mechanical
loading so if we're eating baby food
we're eating the mushy stuff and you
don't have the mechanical loading um you
can't just have one without the other
there's some other stuff going on there
um listen I'm not saying don't brush
your teeth if you want fresh breath go
brush your teeth but this isn't really
fixed the root cause and so I think over
time that this is really what what she
got fed up about she was like
I'm not addressing the root cause I'm
just fixing you know Band-Aid Solutions
and and she starts talking to them about
nutrition Western a price wrote this
book nutrition physical degeneration all
about this stuff it's really well
documented
um and uh she starts talking to him
about you know hey let's get you eating
liver let's get you having some bone
marrow some egg yolk some midday sun and
the patients are like just fix my teeth
you know just fix my teeth and then as
she starts to say Hey listen I'm done
doing all this she's frustrated she
needs to go be a mom
um I start thinking well how do we get
this kind of nourishment how do we
address the root cause and and so that's
kind of where a supplement idea came up
to me and I thought man this is way
bigger than this like look at how we
addressed our kids root cause there's so
much more good we can do spreading this
message so I think we did a pretty
Kick-Ass job in dentistry
um we at the end of it um we own a six
million dollar building she sold the
practice which was a about a five
million sale for the practice so we did
a decent job we struggled a lot through
those years you know we couldn't make
payroll a lot not through those years
you know um because we overbought the
real estate but guess what at the end of
it we own the real estate explain over
buying real estate what exactly that
meant yeah um she saw this building at
the at this intersection this really
fancy intersection I don't know if
anybody knows Houston it's called River
Oaks
um it's it's like the most affluent
neighborhood in Houston and one day
she's like hey I want to buy that
building I'm like okay uh let's go see
how much it costs and I think we had
like uh three or four hundred thousand
dollar budget
um well the building was three million
then there's a couple more million to
build out and and so uh the bank was
dumb enough to loan us the money to buy
it you know and the covenants of of the
loan are like well I got to keep my job
because I I was doing pretty good
um but then we couldn't afford the node
anymore payroll wasn't working out and
so I had to quit the corporate job to
come figure that out and I mean
everything was being repossessed we had
everything really oh the banks are
calling
um and I'm like I can't I tell the front
I can't talk to them on the phone I
gotta go make money you know if they
they want to come visit they got to come
here I'm in crisis mode like and and I'm
so glad we went through this too because
we figured that out too you know if you
figure out enough things like that you
have enough rights of Passage I think
this is what ends up like really
building a high courage oh man we could
do anything uh so it wasn't smooth
sailing but that's what I mean by we
overbought the real estate we couldn't
afford it we figured out a way to barely
make payroll several times I mean
several times we just had to get uh cash
advances on the credit cards right but
after all the cash advances were done on
the credit card to make payroll you know
then there's something called Care
Credit we would we would do that we
would find some way to sell something to
get something for for payroll you know
and meanwhile I thought oh God we're
losers like and my confidence was really
rocked you know I thought oh we could do
a lot of stuff maybe maybe I can't do
this maybe I can't do anything
um and then at the end of it you look
like you know what we we still got this
building and and now what the building
is generating for passive income for the
rentals we have is pretty like oh we did
that this is what we walked away we
still owned it today we still own it
today so you sell the practice is that
the first time that you guys put like
material money in your bank account
well it's really funny because of all
the debts that we had you know like we
ended up paying off our debts so we've I
remember we're down to one car in a
rental house really we we went from the
Range Rovers the big house all this
stuff uh down to a rental house and we
shared one old white beat up Chevrolet
yeah we didn't really have money to put
in the bank and so when you do that why
jump back in to start another business
why not go back and say you know what I
was pretty good at doing the the medical
sales yeah I thought about that oh trust
me I I was talking to everybody hey man
you think I should come back
um because I knew that was easy you know
and I know that you know this like
usually the easiest thing is probably
not the best
um but then I thought man I'm an
evolutionary Hunter like if I were going
to design my next business what I would
make sure is I don't make the same
mistakes I had a brick and mortar right
that was open from like seven to seven
one location one little spot of like you
know what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
figure this thing out what's my real why
in the world my kids weren't healthy we
figured out how to get them healthy
um how would I like to sell this right I
would like to sell it 24 7 365 across
all continents in 55 countries right
it's always available and so I started
to write this stuff down I'm like okay
you know what I I this is actually my
why in the world you know and and I know
how to do this and so well I said I knew
how I I believed we could do it figure
it out yeah and so it's really
interesting I tried to hire Consultants
hey how do you start this kind of
business nobody would help me you know
and so it's just one [ __ ] step at a
time you know it's wild what you could
do after five or six steps and then
eventually you know we have one product
how much of the beginning is like you
sitting down there's a story
um uh Scott Adams got a book uh and he
talks about the two different political
campaigns in 2016 Hillary Clinton and uh
Donald Trump and the way that he
positions it in the book is he says that
uh Hillary Clinton was very much you
know the political machine and uh they
do all their testing of all the
different mottos and messages and all
the stuff and they do their focus groups
and they get it back and they end up
coming up with the slogan I think it was
stronger together right and uh the way
that it describes in the book is what
the Trump walks into a room and they're
like hey we need a motto and he like
thinks for a second he's like make
America great again right I'll tell you
right now that's me because I I my motto
is
fire fire fire aim fire fire fire will
aim right like my motto is take [ __ ]
Massive Action at whatever you do make
all the mistakes because I make all the
mistakes man but I course correct along
the way and and at the end of this the
trajectory where do you end up I can't
tell you how many brilliant people I
know that are still talking about this
business idea right they're still way
back here way smarter all the financing
Financial backing in the world and and
they're like still at like step two or
three yeah you know so I'm definitely
the latter when it comes to that and I
also think it's like an intuition thing
right like some people have intuition
other people may have intuition they
don't trust their intuition and so they
do the testing or whatever and there's
Arguments for for both I don't think
either one's like right or wrong I think
it's just you got to know who you are um
so you guys started the business uh do
you raise capital for it do you just
like figure out some way to get a
website up like what do you do you know
we uh
but the sale of the practice we were
able to pay off debts uh pretty much I
was able to clear some credit cards I
was able to use seven thousand dollars
on a credit card to place a PO
um I learned how to this is before the
Shopify stuff
um so I I learned some coding I learned
to make a website uh I I built it all in
the kitchen in our kitchen I'm making
the website I'm taking the pictures I
did it's just me you know now I'm
handling all the emails and I didn't
raise any capital I I put seven thousand
dollars on the credit card you know as
soon as we started to make some money
and I started thinking oh my God like
this is actually going to work so it's
pretty much profitable from day one
because it had to be it sounds like
um not really because uh then we're just
living off credit cards because
um it actually did so well that um
and now we've got a place a bigger peel
and a bigger Po and a bigger Po and and
then you know what I can't do this by
myself anymore and so I ended up hiring
a guy for next to nothing and I and I
remember the resentment I'm paying you
this money next to nothing it's hardly
any money and I'm not making any money
yet and so you know that's what happens
you know a lot of times in business at
the beginning of business is you get
paid last you know dead last so that
happened um I would say probably took
about maybe a year year and a half you
know to to really start to see the
profits coming from it and while you're
doing this you're still into working out
uh kind of uh lifting weights doing all
this stuff oh yeah um I've always been
obsessed with that
um here's the thing I didn't leave my
house for years I mean like I wanted my
kid wanted some like workout bar from
downtown I'm like oh that's awesome you
want a workout bar but I can't drive you
because all I'm doing is this you know
from five in the morning to like
midnight this is all I'm doing you know
customer emails are coming in people
that are sharing their Health crisis and
I know I have to be there for them right
and so this is it's like 20 and not only
am I handling all of these emails to
take care of the customer
um but then I'm I'm doing the packaging
and then I'm driving to the post office
you know because it's time for me to go
to the post office
um it's it's wild I mean this is what I
did and people don't realize that this
structure this mechanism is like pretty
much all these Amazon sellers there are
hundreds if not thousands or tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands whatever
in the United States uh and also
globally but in the United States where
these small businesses basically exist
online and this is the daily routine of
people yeah they basically get orders
they respond with the customer they do
whatever with their widget that they're
selling and then they either leave it
outside for uh you know Amazon or the
post office or whatever or they drive
there yeah and if you go and you stand
in a post office and like pretty much
any town in America you will see the
small business owners that are selling
stuff online come in drop stuff off and
do it every day yeah so that's to your
question related to working out I mean
if I had customer emails there's no way
I could go work out but I had to work
out so I would do whatever I needed to
do and I would say okay if I can get
caught up to this Mount and there's only
one or two emails I'm gonna go in there
as fast as I can go get a work and I'll
get a couple of mini workouts and doing
that so I was still able to do that and
how big are you at that point like how
much do you weigh you think uh 175 175
pounds all right and so as the business
starts to grow this is I'm assuming
we're getting now into like the late
2010s or so kind of 2018 2019 somewhere
in that range right you at some point
are like I want to grow the business so
like let me create liver king or like
how does that idea kind of come into
your mind before you even do anything
so I I already had a couple of
businesses so now you got multiple
businesses yeah I'm like you you know
what um
I don't know if you've heard this but
but the why has been because my kids
right and then you realize how
desperately people are hurting and so
um you've probably heard these
statistics but I just want to say it one
more time um 85 of the population
struggles with self-esteem issues 80
struggle paycheck to paycheck and you
got to figure out why is that why do we
spend more money than we make right and
a lot of times it's because we're trying
to express our worth and value with [ __ ]
that we buy on a credit card right
instead of going in here and expressing
our worth in value seventy percent of
the population are overweight half are
obese 50 on prescription medicine 40
however will get cancer and twenty
percent want to have kids and can't have
kids so and I'm getting all these emails
in and and I see how desperately they're
hurting and how they hate their lives
and I'm seeing this simple solution
ancestral living these nine ancestral
tenants sleep eat move Shield connect
cold Sun fight and bond somebody comes
to us with a neurocognitive issue and
and they're asking for a product
suggestion like a product suggestion you
know have you ever heard of ketosis
right have you ever heard of egg yolks
have you ever heard of getting the Sun
have you ever heard of these ancestral
tenants here's what we need to be
talking about and and if if we can start
to ratchet up some health improvements
there then let's start talking about
some of the notes-to-tail stuff that you
could be doing and it's so funny because
I can't tell you almost every time
they're like hold on a second do you
sell sunshine are you selling egg yolks
you know what we're doing is we're
selling a path to a better life and when
you see that work so successfully in a
business you know what I got to do more
of this and so I opened up more
businesses and the goal is to open up
businesses that sell ancestral living in
every category of business and so when I
talk about strong jaw this is the
category it's the dental category we
have a canine category coming up we have
a gut category coming up a
neurocognitive if I'm going to get this
message out this is one of the house so
you know the why this is one of the hows
that we're going to do it how many
businesses you got today about 10 10 and
how many you think that you can get to
we're gonna get to 100. you think you're
gonna have a hundred businesses we're
gonna get to 100 in every different
category this message is going to go
mainstream and people still go to the
dentist every single day thinking that
they're going to brush and floss and
they have recurrent Decay and they can't
figure out why do I have to current
Decay and guess what they have much more
deep health issues this is a sign of
what's really going on in the rest of
the body
um this is not okay we're gonna have to
change this Paradigm we have to change
the program you know it's not what how
you brush and floss your teeth this is
how we're going to have to educate and
it's all nine ancestral tenants and
we're predominantly going to meet people
here in this category and that's going
to go in every respective category so
it's just I just want to be really clear
the vision has never changed we have to
acknowledge that people are hurting at
record rates there's a better simple
solution to go forward and so businesses
are kicking ass
you went 10 for 10 or did you have
businesses that you tried and they
failed and then you moved on to the next
one we're 10 for 10 10 for 10 doing this
okay and what's the craziest one that
maybe people wouldn't know about
well I don't even know what how would
you define crazy what do you mean what's
the one that you're like oh people have
no clue that this is even a business
that we have
probably most of them don't know here's
the thing let's just go through what's
the first one the first one if it's okay
with you I don't want to promote any of
my businesses if anybody really wants to
know you could go look it up online
um but but this is getting to your
question
um the whole liver King when did liver
King come in here
um liver King came in because I can't
tell you how many people come to our
house and they're like holy [ __ ] like
you guys live this way well this is of
course we live this way like how do you
live and Time After Time the people be
like dude you got to go on social media
you know time after time people like
they got to make a documentary about you
guys the way that you do all nine of
these ancestral tenants like you you
guys are out of a movie and um and so
the vision is to raise awareness people
are hurting here here's here's the data
right and here's the solution forward
I'm like how do I do a better job at
that and the way that you live I think
this is the first time I ever saw a
piece of content from you was uh there
was a tour of your house
I thought you're [ __ ] crazy man right
I'm telling you that
um you uh I think you basically start
and immediately you're talking about uh
Faraday bags grounded uh house uh at one
point you talked about like the ethernet
cord so like unplugged from all the
devices so just like why is the
structure of the home forget the
workouts the food all that but just like
the home itself what is like the general
idea you're trying to protect like radio
waves or Electronics I mean Forest
Shield right and early ancestors had to
shield from lions and neighboring tribes
and the illusion of danger is kind of
gone like oh we're safe but we're really
bombarded with so many horrific things
you had a guest on recently that was
talking about uh Plastics and phytates
and how that affects hormone those are
hormone disruptors those are all around
us right but but a lot of those things
that you can see and there's a lot of
data on those things
um we're now we're swimming in an
experiment non-native emfs so you come
in our house and if you have we don't
want you to bring your cell phone in our
house but if you're going to bring your
cell phone in our house it goes into
Fair Day container what happened so I
take my cell phone I put it in that bag
what's that bag doing that that's
beneficial yeah it's blocking any input
or output from the phone so basically
the phone's dead I can't use it for all
intensive purposes yeah that's right uh
same thing with with Wi-Fi you know
people like how are you gonna do your
thing do your businesses yeah have you
ever heard of ethernet you know how many
people have never heard of ethernet
connection they're faster they're more
secure you know I'm like
um so you have no Wi-Fi in the house we
don't have any Wi-Fi in the house yeah
so uh and again like all this is
um there's some data on voltage-gated
calcium channels and how that affects
cells and cells can't um uh sell signal
to each other to express their default
functions there's some data on that but
I would say listen
um Let's Pretend There's not we're doing
an experiment we've never had non-native
emfs the way we do now what is a
non-native EMF so there's natural emfs
that come from the Sun that come from
solar flares
um there's uh EMF pulses that just
happen naturally
on Earth but but now everyone in here
with a phone has the running an
experiment and look at how many there
are and normally now like in Office
Buildings and apartments and all this
stuff everybody has Wi-Fi there's modems
everywhere you know and EMS sensitive
people can't even tell you here's what I
feel from this and so we built our house
as a sanctuary like this is where we're
gonna heal rest recover do our best work
I think the Sleep environment absolutely
needs to be pristine most people won't
argue about the Sleep environment so we
make sure the Sleep environment is
perfect and this is how we've built our
house and it's funny you said these
things because once again when you live
this way if you were to say hey man
describe your house I wouldn't describe
any of that this is just how we live so
when you're saying this like it kind of
reminds me how neurotic and obsessive we
are and like our kids are in here our
kids are developing you know as my
obligation to make sure that they have
the best shot they can be you have a
flip phone or you got a like a
smartphone yeah I got a regular phone
you carry it around or no okay what do
you do with it uh well so like right now
yeah right now it's just like just in an
average day are you carrying your phone
around your pocket what are you doing to
uh increase the odds that you're living
a more healthy kind of intercession
still have access to them not so we have
we have a regular phone at the house so
you want to call me like there's a
landline you call me on my landline
um I just started cracking up because
Derek shared my email with the world
again hundreds of emails from people and
people found my phone number too they're
calling that too
um but uh but my phone is on airplane
mode I would say 99 of the time it's on
airplane mode so it's like is this a
phone or is it a Swiss army knife and I
really use it as a camera and so I'll
record when I need to record from it
I'll take it out of airplane mode maybe
or I might leave it in Airplane mode and
just plug in the ethernet with an
adapter and do what I need to do to
upload to social so I don't talk on my
phone like myself you don't talk really
every once in a while I shouldn't say
never
um uh every once in a while I'll have a
phone conference but if the phone
conversation should happen on the
landline if that doesn't happen we're
out and about I'll do a speakerphone and
I'll talk for a minute but if you're
asking like where's my phone my phone's
not in my pocket my phone's like usually
I call them my places right like they're
it's usually in my office or it's in the
gym or it's another you know place and
so I have a couple of different phones I
just leave there like if I need my phone
to go record which is really my camera
that's what I go and get yeah it's it's
fascinating and then you mentioned sleep
um what do you do uh from like a sleep
hygiene or sleep routine what does that
process look like that you've now found
works for you yeah I I'm so glad you
asked because this kind of ties in
everyone's gonna like most people like
hey dude you're so crazy I'm not going
to do any of that yeah um and we know
that most people won't do that so what
are some things that they can do you
know and so from a sleep hygiene
standpoint the best way to set up your
sleep is by getting early morning sun
Through The Eyes on the face on the skin
first thing in the morning we need to
get this exposure even when it's
overcast outside and two minutes is
better than none five minutes is better
than two I always say if you can aim for
five to ten do that and so first thing
you should like literally you get up you
go pee and then go outside or you go
right outside I go outside okay I take a
piss on my favorite tree outside all
right uh I get the sun on me I have my
bare feet connected to the ground and
I'm making a video at the same time so
you're sun and your balls in the morning
too no no I mean if you got your thing
out right
oh well technically if I'm taking a piss
that's what I'm saying I I wanted to
push back on that because liver King
sons is balls at nine o'clock in the
morning or seven o'clock somebody made a
video about this calling it a tenant to
Sun your balls in your ass and I'm like
hold on where did you get that for I'm
like hey guy whoever said that I'm like
that might be your tenant let that be
your tenant but like I just want to make
it really clear this guy has never gone
on record saying to do that but
technically you know early ancestors
would have had some exposure when
they're taking a piss and you go outside
you get the sun uh early in the morning
okay that's right uh so so I get that
part done so uh in terms of sleep get
early morning sun Through The Eyes on
the face on the skin right
um you want to finish your last meal
three to four hours before bed and then
it's really important to take in the
sunset as the final environmental cue
that the day is winding down this is
really important
um and you don't want to come back in
the house to all the artificial lights
it either you can have those lights off
and just have fire light in the house
which I know isn't really practical for
people or you can put on these uvex
glasses that will block a lot of those
those lights and so these are there's
there's 20 if you want to know all 20
things you should go to liverking.com
there's a nine essential tenants ebook
it's free
um there's a lot but those are the like
three or four main things that that will
do but like you sleep uh I think in the
video you sleep on like a wood wood
plank bed what is that yeah you know
well today like what is it that people
sleep on today yeah you know when you go
visit with modern day Prim of culture
tribes there's not a no like look at
beds today they're the perfect height
you just barely fall into it you know
and you wonder why people keep hitting
snooze they're so comfortable like they
just stay in there's like a cast they
have these metal Springs that can also
conduct ambient electricity you need to
be in this deep parasympathetic state
again even if you take this out of the
equation most mattresses are off-gassing
you know and and you can get an off a
non-toxic non-offgasmic mattress but if
you look at modern day primitive
cultures they don't have these beds at
this height they're on the ground and
you have 70 80 year olds that that can
do full squats get up and down from the
ground without using their hands if you
continue to use that kind of Mobility
you won't lose that kind of mobility and
that Mobility also converts uh balance
and Agility benefits so you don't break
a hip because you know what happens when
you break your hip man like you're
almost done all the comorbidities that
happen when you break a hip um these
modern day permanent culture traps are
kicking our ass in life and so this is
one of the things that we've learned
from them that we took back home my wife
uh wanted just to sleep directly on the
floor and and with no padding nothing
I'm like hold on a second it doesn't
seem very evolutionarily consistent
wouldn't we have some plant material
babies some dirt maybe something and
she's hardcore you know and so after a
year or two of trying that like I got
Bone bruises that aren't getting any
better she's like I love it it I love
doing this you know I'm like not me and
so uh we we got about maybe that much
cushion that simulates some some plant
material so that's why we sleep on the
wooden plank bed is because
um it elevates it a little bit because
of humidity there's no more mold or
moisture that creates any massive issues
so that that's a big deal and like I
said there's like 20 things if you read
The ancestral tendency ebook which is
free you'll see all of them I think the
big things are that most people don't
because again people aren't going to go
do that almost no one's going to go and
do that get early morning sun finish
your last meal three or four hours
before bed take in the sunset as a final
environmental cue and then block the
blue lights hopefully with with the uh
UVS classes got it so you've been living
this life right and it works for you it
works for your family uh there's some
people who are like yup I agree with
everything he just said and I'm trying
to do all that [ __ ] I got a faraday bag
I got the glasses I'm eating uh liver or
whatever there's other people who are
like bro shut the [ __ ] up I'm eating
McDonald's and like good luck right and
everyone in between but what I find
fascinating about your story is what is
all the information that's not come out
is you basically called your shot on the
liver King thing right so I saw some of
the emails uh Derek for more plates more
dates uh uh published and I listened to
one of the interviews you did with Chris
Williamson over at uh modern wisdom and
one of the things in the in uh in one of
the emails is basically like I'm going
to get a million followers and I'm gonna
do this this and this and I was like
you know the crazy part is not that he
wrote the [ __ ] that he went and did it
and so forget for a second the steroids
and kind of all the controversy and
stuff talk about the invention of liver
King right because I think that what
many people don't understand about the
internet is that most of the [ __ ] you
see on the internet is not real life
like I always say Twitter's not real
life right it's like yeah you might be
using your real name you might be re
using your real photo you may think you
don't have uh uh you know another uh um
you know character or anything that
you're using on the internet
but come on if I talk to you in person
at dinner and then I see what you're
tweeting you're a different person on
the internet you drew a line in the sand
and you were like there's me and there's
liver King to some degree and so like
what was the the idea or the strategy I
would say most of that is to a degree
you know earlier you said
um about the email how do I bring
everything to me you know um I'm really
good at focusing and if you don't have
to drive in your car or go anywhere or
deal with any [ __ ] conversations
it's like you know how much more
productive you can be when you know what
your roles and goals are you can say I'm
going to have a million followers by
March 2nd and this is not even a full
year you know I'm like I know I can do
that and this I remember the guys I'm
talking to everyone's laughing
they had to hold their laugh back they
were almost embarrassed they're laughing
in my face I'm like listen I know this
is an unreasonable goal it will take
unreasonable things for us to get there
but I know we can do this I believe in
it and what I need for you to do is not
laugh at it just to say hey man if
you're willing to do anything and
everything it takes to get here we can
do that and so this is why if if I need
to meet with an accountant I don't go to
the accountant the accountant comes to
me same thing with a lawyer same thing
with any meeting that I have that they
all come to me so that I can stay
focused on my main roles and goals as as
a husband as a father as a primary role
to express my highest most dominant form
as a man as a CEO of the ancestral
lifestyle and so whenever all this
happened I'm like okay this is the goal
and there wasn't really this line in the
sand per se what I said if I'm going to
do this I'm going to call it passive
income you guys are going to record most
of what I do I sleep eat move Shield
connect called Sun fight and bond this
way every day so I'm gonna do this what
you guys are going to do is keep up with
me and record this now is it all 100
percent like that I would say there's no
doubt there are days where I feel like
[ __ ] and I wake up and I say good
morning primals it's prime time to do
this like [ __ ] I feel like [ __ ] you know
really what I need to do is take a cold
shower you know I think yesterday or
today this is what my good morning
primer was like I don't really feel very
good you know and I'm doing more of that
right now
um but but I would say
um sure there's some elements to liver
King the character but the the thing is
most of what we do is really my truest
Primal authentic self on there one of uh
one of the guys on our team always says
like everything's the WWE right of just
like it wrestling is such a good uh uh
comparison to the rest of the world
because everyone is putting on their
face they're putting on the ACT they're
doing all this
um
and there's positives and negatives to
it obviously uh creating the liver King
character has led to a bunch of positive
you've talked about this uh Ad nauseam
and I think that uh it's not just around
eating certain things or working out or
whatever there's mental health benefits
like all of that but there's also this
uh danger of audience capture where all
of a sudden and I've even had it happen
to myself where you're like the audience
expects me to do X if I deviate from
acts they're gonna come for me yeah
they're gonna they're gonna expose me
they're gonna do this they're gonna piss
me off you know whatever the thing is
have you had that like was it something
that you realized like oh [ __ ] like I
have been captured by the audience to
some degree or is it something that like
maybe now you're realizing the steroids
or something else just in general no
I'll say in general again like this this
is the relieving thing it's like if I'm
gonna go on social media you guys are
gonna record what I do this is how I eat
this is how I live you know like people
are especially right now saying liver
King's a character
um this is how we live our life and you
know what's crazy this is how liver
Queen lives her life too we're all
eating raw liver and raw testicle and
raw bone marrow every single day you
know and all of it's revealed in the
stories I couldn't imagine how
exhausting it would be to probably make
five six seven eight stories a day my
good morning primals what I eat how I
work out the liver King philosophy going
on a walk I mean there's so many things
that are in here like oh my God what if
I like I don't know how exhausting that
would be if a WWE character had to do
that and how sustainable and scalable so
I'm like
um I've never really been worried about
getting caught yeah other than what
what's just happened but in terms of
expressing my Primal True Form This is
what you know the reason why I came up
with the name liver King wasn't really
just to like capture this Larger than
Life character it's I gotta get this
message across that liver is King if you
don't let take anything else from this
podcast or when when you meet this guy
it's like oh he's talking all this
nonsense just remember one thing if
you're gonna just do one thing overlay
on top of your you don't have to change
your life just start eating liver and
when people start eating liver they feel
the difference and so this is the
message I wanted to get across and
normally I say liver King here here's
what liver King's having for dinner
liver King out and I've said it three
times and somewhere in there I always
say because liver is King and that's and
now when I meet people all over the
place like hey liver King let's do this
thing and I'm like hold on hold on why
is my name liver King let's talk about
that do you know why and impressively a
lot of people know why like thank God
and then I say are you eating it well
most of the time they're not like well
if all I'm doing is entertaining you
then I'm failing you you have to be
eating it and then I go home and I
figure out how do I get people to
connect more deeply with this message so
that it can change and impact their life
I know I've said a lot there but I would
say that
um I never really drew a line in the
sense that okay here's Brian Johnson and
here's liver King it really has been
like okay we're going to record the way
that I live my life I do these crazy
workouts I eat these crazy things I
sleep this way we live this way and so
the nice thing is it really hasn't been
exhausting could you have gotten as big
on social media if you did under Brian
Johnson the name yeah or do you think
that do you think the The Branding the
like the character right even though it
is a reflection of what you do every day
uh it was important to get the social
following you know
um so before social following
I had a beard before social following I
didn't wear a shirt you know before
social following like I looked spoke
talk like this guy you know um and and
so
you scared of shirts
well you know what I'm scared of not
getting sung you know and and also
um I think it is important to know you
know again like before social I didn't
wear a shirt so now I'm going on social
and I'm wearing a shirt now actually I'm
playing a character you know so I didn't
feel comfortable trying to play a
character you know again it's like okay
so now we're recording let me hold on
guys let me put my shirt on you know I
was like I'm going to go do this stuff
you guys just recorded you know and half
the time Where's Thomas Thomas is like
hey I didn't get that I'm like he says
can we do it again I said no you got to
keep up with me you don't do you don't
do second takes I I sometimes I will but
I you know what
um you might call it Roid Rage you know
like I've never had patience I always
say in life you get what you tolerate
you get what you demand I demand the
most of myself so I demand the most of
the people around me I don't have a lot
of patience you better keep up with me
and so imagine if I started to say oh
hold on you're recording let me go put a
shirt on
um how different would it be if I call
myself Brian Johnson didn't have a beard
and I don't know look like everybody
else probably pretty significantly
different yeah you know but but then I
also think about
um think about how effortless it is that
I get my message across the name is
liver King because liver is King
that that's if I can do that you know I
don't know if you listen to The Joe
Rogan ones with Derek but in that in
that message Joe Rogan said how great
liver is and that he eats it all the
time Derek said that he eats it every
day all I heard was liver is king that's
all I heard and I'm like you know how
great this is yeah I don't think anyone
has an issue with the ancestral living
uh with liver is King like like all
those things I think actually most
people are like no he's 100 right on
that stuff it's like 95 of the message
people are like yep and we need more
people doing that and whether it's you
whether it's Superman whether it's you
know uh uh Rogan whoever is like pushing
this message forward is uh a hundred
percent what more people need to hear
about
um we've even had people come on uh uh
there's this one guy Texas slim I don't
know if you've come across him yet uh
but he talks all about like how
corrupted the food supply system is and
uh cattle ranchers are basically you
know uh the big uh cattle companies
basically got on by the balls right and
they're making them do things they don't
want to do and all this stuff and it's
just economics at Play okay um so I'm
thinking people people have a problem
with that the steroid thing obviously
people got a problem with
um but I'm gonna do my best to unpack
what I think is a Nuance here uh but I
need to caveat with I don't [ __ ] know
anything about this [ __ ] so you're going
to give me a little bit of an education
but when people hear steroids what I
think they think of is Arnold
Schwarzenegger they think of like uh you
went you bought steroids in like a back
alley you're jabbing it in your ass and
like let's see what happens uh that is
like maybe one extreme we'll call it the
back alley steroid uh use then there is
uh what I think has become socially uh
more understood acceptable uh and uh
maybe talked about which is like this
hormone therapy stuff where people are
like yo testosterone's down a [ __ ] ton
over the last couple of decades
why is that happening and what can men
do about it and so that's maybe like the
other end of the extreme if you had to
explain to people that don't understand
a lot about steroids or hormones or
whatever like where are you on that
Spectrum in terms of what you've been
doing is it just the hormone stuff is it
somewhere in between like how would you
think of that Spectrum yeah
um there's been times where it's been in
between okay and when I tried it in
between this is why I reached out to
Derek and that coaching guy because I
needed help because my blood chemistries
got [ __ ] up because my lipids got high
uh my my liver enzymes Got High and um
and I did have a clinician monitoring me
the whole time and so but my clinician I
felt like wasn't as valuable so I'm like
okay let me get a second opinion let me
get a third opinion let me figure this
out
um we came off of some of those other
things which were the Winstrol in the
nandra loan and stayed on testosterone
and growth hormone and then everything
looked pretty good and so technically I
had somebody tell me the other day hey
man don't tell people that you're on
steroids because what you're on is trt
and growth hormone you're on HRT you're
on hormone and I said listen do you know
how
I I I haven't been forthcoming I haven't
been honest so what I need to do now is
over share I've been on steroids I'm on
steroids now you know technically
testosterone is a steroid growth hormone
is not a steroid it's a peptide hormone
for all intents and purposes like these
are PEDs right these are things that
help us in the gym help us to recover
help to build muscle help to lose fat
like there's no doubt that these things
you know so so we draw the uh kind of
Line in the Sand of like the trt the
growth hormone that is more like hormone
therapy type stuff right that I think
people are talking about many of the
folks who have been talking about you
take it they openly share you know Pros
cons why they do it it's important to
say that that's HRT if if it's managed
in the normal range for this I don't
know hormone replacement therapy
um if you're above the like uh the the
normal physiology if it's super
physiological well I think now you're
talking like bodybuilder levels or
something like that and so this is like
Winstrol and all these other things what
is the difference of the impact on the
body right so so you said when you took
some of the other stuff outside of just
the hormone replacement therapy that you
started to get [ __ ] up basically yeah
like why do people take it and what is
the intended uh outcome when they put
that in their body yeah I don't know why
uh I can't speak for other people you
know I'll just say for me
um I have to get into the gym multiple
times a day and it's at least two times
a day sometimes that's more times a day
and this isn't like just doing regular
workouts I mean even when I show on on
my stories it's like I only show three
or four things that I do I'd probably do
six seven eight things you know like I
gotta take myself to this point where I
know I'm crushing myself where I'm
destroying myself and it's like okay
that makes me feel good enough for a
while until I have to do it again and I
have to do that at least at least twice
a day for me to look at myself in the
mirror like before I go to bed I sleep
good by the way sleep good and I do have
self-worth but that's what's required of
me to have self-worth and if I leave out
one of those I don't yeah how old are
you I'm 44. so 40 for and I'm assuming
that like most men at some point in your
30s you started to feel like uh hey I
can't do the same amount of volume of
workouts and intensity uh that you
previously were doing it is that
something that you think hormone
replacement therapy uh most men in
America are going to experiment with and
like can get back to how they know what
I hope more than anything is that the
first thing they look at are the nine
ancestral tenants these things that our
early ancestors have done since the
beginning of time 50 years ago we had
almost
50 higher testosterone it's really clear
things are happening today in the modern
world and and if you look at modern day
primitive culture tribes that are
kicking ass they're neurochemistry is
pretty good I don't know if their
hormones have been measured but you know
the low-hanging fruit here really is
sleep eat move Shield connect cold Sun
fight now there's work that has to go
into that there's no doubt about that my
hope and goal like is people who said
hey so you can be an advocate for it now
and I'll say this is nuanced you know
for a young person hell no you know
there's no place there's no form of it
unless you have hypogodasism instead of
like instead of uh or unless there's
like a physiological impairment for you
to produce adequate tests there's no
place for it if you're a young person
um now I think if you're I don't know in
your mid-30s and you know about some of
these natural levers like the nine
ancestral tenants and you're doing this
stuff
um give yourself that shot now if you're
doing this stuff and you still have low
testosterone if you feel like [ __ ] if
you look like [ __ ] if you function like
[ __ ] go talk to someone who knows their
[ __ ] and have that conversation and
decide for themselves there's no doubt
that our test I mean you probably know
some of the statistics right A lot of it
has to do with xenoestrogens and
phytoestrogens and if you just Shield
properly and get your estrogen exposure
down you know what a difference that
makes if you start sleeping all of these
things make such a big impact on your
hormones and our neurochemistry and
sleep is probably the biggest lover you
start getting early morning sun you
finish your last meal early you take in
the sunset you block out all these blue
lights blue lights instead of looking at
your phone right before bed and you can
do that if you have your ufx glasses on
if you just fix your sleep your
testosterone will go up at 10 your
growth hormone will go up a ton you know
um I do think that as we get older we're
not meant to still be in this Warrior
archetype well we're working out two or
three times a day you know there's
something I'm dealing with internally
that I never really faced before not
until all of this came out right and
then I said well you know what I got to
do this every day I gotta get into the
gym when I'm on vacation I gotta get
into the gym yesterday we had a really
busy day I crushed myself in the morning
and then we ordered dinner I'm like oh
well guess what I gotta go do this thing
again before we go and eat
um this is again what I have to do and
then somebody said well why do you have
to do that and again I know I'm dealing
with this you know I think it probably
Harkens back to my 10 to 15 year old
self I think it Harkens back to like
when I figured out that I I was strong
and I doubled down on that and it's like
okay before that I felt worthless and
then I figured out man if I can do that
I think I'm capable of anything and so
par so this is what is required of me to
feel this way so to me it's pretty deep
to me there's a lot of stuff that I need
to do but I think that there's a time
and a place for it and so I'm glad to be
able to talk about it now I think it's
just really important to know if there's
a time and a place and you're trying to
do these things naturally
um how much you want to bet most people
will have such a meaningful this happens
every day I get tons of DMS every day I
felt like [ __ ] I had issues with my
hormones and I started following some of
these things and now I feel way better
I'm building more muscle I'm finally the
husband that my wife married I'm finally
the dad that that my boys deserve
because I started doing these [ __ ]
things I'm like oh God thank God so
people need to do these things because
they work
um let's say people are doing these
things and it's not working out go go
get monitored no matter what you gotta
go to a trained hormone clinician you
just try and go to a guy at the gym you
know and you're going to take something
that might not be pure you know you
might do a whole lot more harm than good
and you've got to get monitored you know
like for me to figure out my exact dose
I had to get monitored I have such a
specific dose you know for me to feel
the way to feel good and to make sure it
doesn't happen effect on my lipids or
any other chemistry I needed the exact
dose and I wouldn't know that without
being monitored remember you're talking
to a complete idiot about this stuff so
I'm asking you some basic questions you
just shoot yourself with a needle in the
ass like what is the application process
well I'm glad you're asking because I
think one of my sons actually asked uh
mom that the other day
um so growth hormone is right here in
the stomach or right here on the side
just uh it's uh subcutaneous in the fat
um and then once a week we do
testosterone in the ass and yes and like
you selfish and the ass cheek just just
so you guys know
and you're doing it yourself or or
somebody's helping you like how does
that work both you know sometimes I
might do it myself you know sometimes
I'm like liver Queen not feeling real
flexible today helped me out a little
bit
um and and then when you do this uh in
one of the emails I can't remember the
email or maybe one of the conversations
uh you said that you would take it
before you went to work out right and so
could people go and get this stuff they
do it would their bodies change at all
this like if they don't work out what
happens there's the overwhelming
majority of people that are on hormone
replacement therapy and trt testosterone
replacement therapy
um they still look like [ __ ] you know
they might feel better right um and they
might look better but most people I mean
I guess it's important to know if you
think you're going to take that and
you're going to look incredible like you
got another thing coming I mean there's
a lot of work that has to go into it uh
so I would say um I don't know if you've
heard but I'm gonna peel all this stuff
back I'm not gonna take it anymore
you're gonna go completely clean that's
right what's gonna happen to your body
well this is yeah why I wanted to share
this because I hope you'll have me on in
a year yeah um and I'll wait 15 I'm
gonna be bigger than you
you might be but um I mean I know
exactly how I left before yeah and
here's the thing I bet if you saw me
before you're probably like he looks
pretty similar most people in the
fitness industry know the difference uh
so we're talking about a 15 pound
difference so what so you weighed like I
think you said 175 at one point earlier
uh before you took this a year and a
half ago or whatever about 175 and now
you're like 190 200. yeah I'm 195. so so
I I probably am up to one between 175
and 185-ish without anything it was 10
15 pounds basically by coming off of it
and then uh and your social record
um that that's when I had reached out to
get on growth hormone I had been on some
testosterone replacement therapy a
couple of years prior and so when you
reach out to these people one of the
things that uh when I saw all the emails
I saw Derek's thing and I saw a podcast
like oh [ __ ] here we go he's gonna go
he's gonna go through the [ __ ] ringer
and there's one or two paths that you
can choose you can either no that's not
true that's [ __ ] email whatever or
you can just be like yes that's true I'm
sorry right which is how you took
how many people did you email before
liver king became a thing and the reason
why that was one of my first thoughts
was like dude this guy's been living
like this for a year and a half knowing
there's [ __ ] emails out there that
disprove something that he is saying I
saw the biggest podcasts in the world
yeah so was it just Derek and this coach
or did you email like 200 people and
everyone's stupid and didn't check their
200 people no no no no no I was like
holy [ __ ] just the two of them yeah
really so just those two guys basically
are you know very small number of people
that you yeah and I I do want to make it
clear I don't think Derek did anything
wrong you know I called Derek almost
immediately to say thank you for doing
this
um I don't know what good will come of
it but thank you for doing this I asked
him how long it took to make such an
incredible documentary I was really
impressed actually how I put it all
together I mean the way that he went
through the email and read everything I
wrote and the way he laughed at certain
things I'm like oh I would laugh at that
too when he laughed at it I'm like oh I
said that exactly and I'm laughing at it
too the emails are funny I agree like I
don't know how you were riding them I
don't know if you were like ready to you
know put [ __ ] trt in your ass after
you were doing or some [ __ ] but like
they were hilarious thank you you know
um when when he went over I'm like I
said all that and it's me to a t I'm
like well there's no disputing any of
this now and and there's no doubt like I
also saw this as a path you know to to
me be exactly who I need to be to
express who I actually am I I've been
honest about everything else that this
one thing you know this has been
weighing on me for a long time and so if
you like go to sleep and you're like
[ __ ] tomorrow may be the day I figured
out oh no no just just like over the
year and a half when you knew these
emails were out there or did you even
forget that I know that a superpower
that I have is focus and
compartmentalizing and so this is not a
lingering thought that I had
um now I referred to him as the clown
coach the the other guy who had reached
out to and I say that because he made a
video
um saying that he refunded my money that
he's not Tech he was not technically my
coach so if he wasn't technically my
coach was there technically a breach of
confidentiality he's trying to pose
these kind of rhetorical questions so
you're like pretty sure he's the one who
leaked this oh he admits it okay he says
I'm the guy who leaked it and I know
right now he's trying to save face
because he has all of his coaching
clients saying hold on you're going to
leak my information you're telling me
that what we exchange is not
confidential and so is it clout chasing
to some degree I don't know like he
wants he wants to be the guy who like
outed you or is it just like all the
Press is good press like what do you
think's going on you know I'm not really
sure
um but I just want to make it clear
because we're being honest about
everything yeah he did not refund my
money and I'm not asking for a penny
back actually okay how much do you think
you paid him I was probably like five or
six thousand dollars okay all right yeah
yeah exactly listen I don't need a penny
back
um and and he he was my coach and he did
send those emails to somebody else again
I think what he did there's there's some
issues there
um what Derek did to bring all the
information forward I don't think Derek
did anything wrong and there's so many
Silver Linings that have come from this
how much money do you think you've spent
total on steroids hormone replacement
therapy Etc over your life yeah well
there's no doubt it's all comes from the
growth hormone because testosterone is
like maybe 100 120 for like a three
month supply so you take out the
testosterone and all I tried was uh wood
straw and uh and Andrew alone uh maybe
twice for the that that's dirt cheap too
okay um and so you're looking you're
looking at the growth the the better
question probably is like how much you
think you spent on growth hormone
um growth hormone was expensive like how
expensive uh well here's the thing for
me to be in the normal range so at first
it's like oh you just need uh the small
dose so so here's maybe it was like two
thousand dollars a month at first uh and
so I would go and get tested and nothing
would register no growth hormone no igf
one increase
um so it's like okay let's double it
um and so [ __ ] now I'm gonna spend four
thousand a month
um so we tried double again and nothing
happened we tried doubling it nothing
happened and I'm like now we're spending
all this money and nothing's happening
um and my blood chemistry is getting
[ __ ] up I'm getting pretty frustrated
I'm reaching out to Derek I'm reaching
out to this other guy uh for help and uh
finally we got to a pretty high dose
again I don't know if you saw the email
um the clinician thinks I'm I was a
hyper non-responder whatever that means
um but it took a pretty high dose so it
took quite the average person would
never have to spend this much money on
it how much are you spending listen
um I need a number come on what is it
that's enough to buy a car every month a
50 Grand no no not a 50 Grand all right
30 grand do you know the number that he
said in the email I don't remember okay
so the number I think at the time like
10 or 12 was like maybe 10 to 15 000.
okay it's a little bit more than that so
like 20 grand yeah do you think you
spend a quarter million dollars on
growth hormone over the last year and a
half two years yeah oh yeah a million no
no no no no no you're saying that like
it's crazy let me tell you what what's
really incredible about this all right
Derek shared my email with the world
yeah right and so now I have dozens of
emails that have come in that say you
know you're paying double the price
because I ain't going to nobody you know
after I got this locked and loaded uh
but hey guess what the world knows and
so now consistently so many clinicians
and hormone clinics have come in and
said boom here's a new quote it's half
the price we're also a clinic
endocrinologist medical director yada
yada and so far I'm like thank you Derek
for that yeah you know but pretty soon
I'm going to save 100 right now I'm
saving 50 I'll hopefully sooner I get to
save 100 so basically you spend about a
quarter million dollars on steroids and
got a million followers on social media
a quarter billion dollars but but I mean
it just is what it is right like I don't
even think it's necessarily a good thing
or a bad thing because there's a lot of
people who uh take growth hormone for
medical purposes they're under uh uh the
consultation of a physician or whatever
and they're probably spending the same
amount of money right or maybe they're
spending half of that I want to make it
clear very few people will need the
amount that what do you think the
average person the person who's taking
it all the caveats they're supposed to
take it the physician tells them to take
it whatever what do you think they spend
on growth hormone like maybe 50 Grand a
year uh well first of all again keep in
mind I've been a hyper non-responder and
so I think the average person might be
closer to a thousand or two thousand a
month yeah maybe like 12 to 24 000 right
yeah that was public math that was
pretty good on the Fly
um all right I want to talk about one
other thing which is uh Joe Rogan uh
a couple months ago I think was saying
uh no [ __ ] way he's definitely on
steroids just look at him like there's
no way you can do that whatever I saw
you get asked about it and you had like
very nice things to say about Joe and I
think that you were like look I look up
to this guy in some form or fashion uh
enjoys content all this stuff and uh you
took kind of the high road I think in
the response uh he had Derek come on
they had a [ __ ] blast uh and Joe
basically was just like I what are you
guys talking about of course he was on
steroids right what is it like uh Joe
Rogan's got the biggest media platform
in the world he's bigger than all the
mainstream media all this stuff uh what
is kind of your reaction or your
thoughts of seeing that conversation
happen and they're talking about you
it's not they're not talking about
something you do they're talking about
you what are you thinking as you're
watching that yeah well two things
um earlier you had asked about like how
it felt about something and and I'll
tell you how I felt about that initially
is um I feel like a piece of [ __ ] you
know this whole time he's been saying
this this whole time I've been lying so
first thing I feel like is a piece of
[ __ ]
um I also just want to make it clear I'm
not asking for any sympathy I did that I
did all of it I deserve all of it I lied
about it
um I was wrong to do all of that right
um I am sorry for that that's what I'm
sorry for and then I'm watching the two
exchange here
um really there's one one thing that
upset me and it's when he talked about
the 4 000 people today I'm talking about
the 4 000 people today that kill
themselves and the 80 000 people a day
that try and the way that he chuckled
about that pissed me off you know that
pissed me off because I think you got
such a big platform you got a
responsibility and an obligation to
address this
hate me think I'm a clown he's been on
this the whole fine but I I think he
should have paused for a second and said
hold on a second this is not a
conversation about liver King this is
the second we're gonna say this is a
problem and and if you are thinking like
this way you do need to get some help
um I was I was frustrated about that but
then I thought you know they talked
about leverking for 35 minutes I was not
physically on the show and they talked
about me for 35 minutes you know how
many times I've been on Joe Rogan's show
without actually physically being there
he's talked about I can't believe it you
know and then he said he's been front
row at my comedy I saw him at the Canelo
fight I've seen him at the UFC and he's
talked about me so many times
um I guess boys like are you friends
um I've never met him before okay so you
guys never talked before like in person
I've I've always if I've seen him I
would love to have a conversation with
him you know again I think that he what
he's done is incredible I still hold him
in the highest regard I think he's a
giant he's done something that no one
else has ever done and most of the
ancestral tenants he talking about not
in this organized packaged way but he
talks about liver all the time he talks
about thermal pressures and getting cold
and sauna all the time I mean he talks
about virtually all nine ancestral
tenants all the time and so um I'm I'm
really just grateful towards the end of
that he's saying how great liver is the
other guy's saying the heat sliver every
day and really when I'm and thank God
I had already taken this load off me I
made an apology video I did what I
needed to do for me to move forward and
so now he's just making fun of that with
a lot of chocolate and I deserve all of
it the one thing that I think that that
I wish he had done better is addressed
the suicide thing in a different way but
other than that I'm like hey I deserve
it I feel like a piece of [ __ ] I own all
of it bring it all on except for that
one thing and then at the end of it he
bookended it with saying in my opinion
what he said is liver is King I felt
pretty good about that yeah I think
again I think most people all my friends
who you've talked to got on their
podcast uh et cetera is just like yeah
95 of this stuff is like very real and
people should know it they should follow
it they should do all the stuff uh the
steroid thing like I think it's split
actually half of them are like oh he
told me that uh he didn't take steroids
and he did like he lied to me the other
half of them are like
dude are you guys [ __ ] kidding me
like the dude's 45 years old
like he's ripped out of his mind did you
think he wasn't on steroids listen I've
gotten so much of that like hold on you
guys actually didn't think he was
already
um but I also still want to own that a
lot of people gave me the benefit of the
doubt a lot of people believed in me one
guy Joe aesthetic believed in me so
deeply he took 10 minutes to explain to
me and the rest of his community why I'm
natural and that probably tugged up my
heart more than anything else because of
how much he believed in me
um and so I want to take credit for that
you know um nobody had deceived
themselves I I did all that how do you
balance in your head uh
you create liver King you take steroids
uh you absolutely explode on social
media one thing no one will take away
from you is you [ __ ] exploded on
social media you built this massive
audience uh and again 95 of the things
you're talking about there's a lot of
people with big audiences uh who are
very educated much more educated than me
on Fitness and and uh diet and all these
things and they're like yep all this
makes a ton of sense
um
and then there is the uh accusation that
some of those people in the audience are
going and they're buying the supplements
they're doing all this stuff and to me I
don't think people are dumb enough to
actually believe if I take a supplement
I'm going to look like that uh but there
are definitely people who uh say oh this
guy is cool or this is something I
aspire to right and so he has a product
and I go and I buy it so there's like
Nuance to it but but how do you kind of
think through uh uh where maybe the
critics are right and maybe where
they're they're not as accurate uh in
terms of your rise as liver king and the
use of PEDs and then like impact on your
businesses yeah this is really complex
um because overall
we we talked about these statistics and
how desperately people are hurting
people the average person today goes to
a job that they hate they come home to a
life that they don't love they sedate
themselves with enough screen time with
enough [ __ ] that their day's not
really meaningful right
um this is my true north and and so the
critics and and I should be criticized
for so much more than this but the
critics of the ancestral lifestyle
normally what I say is I push back and I
say you had your [ __ ] time you had
your chance your ways didn't work the
world is hurting at record rates I told
you all the statistics none of that's
changed all those are facts you can't
criticize that [ __ ] right and you can't
criticize that what my message is this
is the message of our ancestors of your
ancestors of what you're trying to
critique
um and so I would just say remember that
the true north will always remain the
true north you don't got to buy anything
from me right you don't got to follow me
you don't got to engage with me but you
do have to follow and engage with other
CEOs of the ancestral lifestyle like Ben
Greenfield like Andrew huberman like the
other people that are advancing this
because most people hate their life your
life [ __ ] sucks there's a better life
to live it's called ancestral living and
so the the critique about if I benefited
from from uh this message and my
supplements I'm I'm wrong about all that
again I deserve all that you know and if
somebody wants to go first of all I hope
they don't go anywhere else right but
all I care about is I talk about this
all the time you've got to get liver in
your life because liver is King go on a
hunt first and foremost that kind of
connection with the animal and land will
do more for you than getting it anywhere
else if you can't do that go to the
butcher if you can't go to the butcher
go to the find a way to get liver there
will always be a segment of the
population that's gonna say [ __ ] all
that give me the pill right you don't
got to get it from any of my companies
go get the pill go get the liver pill
from Amazon go do your research go look
at the reviews and go get it from
somebody else don't because of me you
can't be disloyal to the facts that this
is how bad people are hurting and
there's a better way to live you got to
get this into your life you don't got to
get it for me so I would I would just
say I think that there's there's truth
um there's weight to what the critics
have said I deserve it all and if
somebody um again I hope they continue
to engage with the message and all I
care about is go go on that hunt go get
liver go do these dining ancestral
tendons because the world is hurting and
this is a better life to live you've
been incredibly uh I think kind to the
critics in the sense of you're like look
I deserve all this is there one critic
where you're like yo [ __ ] that person
like they've just gone above and beyond
in the hate and just like coming after
you you know what's really interesting
my disposition I don't know if you've
heard me talk about this before I say
this to my kids all the time uh when and
I alluded to this earlier when you read
text or you hear a word right especially
if you hear it like these are broken
down into syllables these vibrations go
into your ear canal your your brain
assigns meaning to it the meaning that I
assign immediately is how bad that
person is hurting and hating their life
and so I've not gotten upset at anybody
I've never said hey man go [ __ ] yourself
you're wrong about all this
um I will say um there's one time that I
felt really frustrated okay
um and uh and it's with this coaching
clown that came up and said all these
lies I really funded his money X Y and Z
the the Silver Lining is here here he's
not unraveling any of the ancestral
tenants you know I think he's just
trying to save himself and I don't even
know why that bothers me you know I
won't even say his name because I don't
want to promote him you know
um but anyone else you say I've been
nice about it um I think I'm glad you're
saying that I'm just being 100 Earnest
and sincere about it when this whole
thing happened uh it's like okay what
what is getting mad gonna do I did this
like if there's anyone to be mad at you
[ __ ] idiot I mean I look at myself
you you [ __ ] for about five seconds
and now guess what man you gotta claw
your your way out of this because the
message is so much bigger than you and
your brand and if your brand is gone
tomorrow I gotta work with a hundred
other CEOs of the ancestral lifestyle
you know sometimes people talk about oh
all this money I make you know because I
make a lot of money all of us make
um well I have three companies that do
100 million plus a year all three to 100
or no
um and this is what I want to say about
that okay what do I do with it you know
what I do with it I make other ancestral
companies I I reinvest that money to
make other ancestral companies other
CEOs of the ancestral lifestyle to
advance this message to have a hundred
ancestral companies and 100 different
categories That's How Deeply I believe
in this so 100 million dollars in
Revenue this is a big ass business 100
million dollars in Revenue how many
employees you think you have
across all the businesses 50 50. that's
[ __ ] two million dollars in Revenue
per employee that's a big that's that's
a fantastic business right yeah is this
something that other people can
replicate or do you think that you have
like unique skills and knowledge to be
able to you know what the I in this
Mastermind group where very few people
have that kind of Revenue to employee
ratio and they're like oh you know and
then I hear how they talk about their
employees and and I'm like that's why
you know because I think the highest
leverage opportunity is to hire True
Believers
um I got into this because of how deeply
I believe in this because of my kids
because of how badly people are hurting
I only hire people in my companies that
have been through a Health crisis that
have recovered their Health crisis
through ancestral living and and through
this whole issue I'm the one who has
compromise I've compromised the
perimeter I know that and that's why
like I better do a goddamn good job
moving forward
um I always say are sustainable
competitive Advantage is we only hire
True Believers we care more deeply and
we care more because you know how many
people want to go do this for for money
of course I'm like oh cool you know like
do you even know what money is and I'm
like let's talk about what money is
money is a proxy for the value that we
create in the world and so all you want
to do is go create more that but you
don't even know why you want to create
it I figured out why I want to create it
because my kids couldn't breathe you
know because of people like Kat who
couldn't have a kid had infertility
issues and started doing ancestral
living now she has a beautiful baby you
know we have an employee Ben who's
bedridden with intractable depression
intractable Crohn's disease and
recovered his life in his kicking ass
because ancestral living there's this
other kid CYO who lost 60 pounds who's
reconnected with the outside world you
see this joy in life that otherwise
wouldn't be possible with ancestral
living so what I would like to say is I
hope there's thousands of people that
replicate this business but you better
do it by putting the why at the center
of of what you're doing because I need
everyone I had one guy come up to me one
time I was like hey man I want to open
up a business just like yours exactly
like yours
um and I said cool cool it goes what do
you mean cool like I'm going to be your
competitor you think you are going to be
my competitor as a listen here's the
issue the world doesn't know about
ancestral living the world doesn't know
about organs and glands if you do a good
job you're my greatest Ally in the world
I'll tell you how to do everything but
here's the thing you don't give a [ __ ]
about people and because you don't give
a [ __ ] about people you can't do this
and you're not the right person but this
is what I need I need hundreds and
thousands of people to say I want
businesses just like you but it has to
come from in here their why has to be
probably because they recovered a Health
crisis themselves or for their family
and then they need to only hire True
Believers because you hire a True
Believer they'll do the work at 10. I'm
sure you know this you hired one right
higher it changes your entire company
imagine if all your hires are the right
hire it changes everything and so this
is uh when I say that this is really
nuanced and complex I don't know if you
heard my apology video I said man this
is complicated as [ __ ] to me and you
know how much criticism about God
they're like no no it's not you're
either on steroids or you're not well
this is one of the complexities the
layers of the nuances I have all these
companies that I've hired with True
Believers that have come here to do some
goddamn good to make the greatest
contribution in the world and I'm
letting them down I have compromised the
perimeter but I also say to the meeting
coming from me you came here because you
had your greatest why in the world
you've recovered this Health crisis and
now you know that you need to do this
with other people if you're here for me
you're not here for the right reason
there's the door but but you're here to
do this and I'm going to do anything and
everything in my power to help create
the right environment the right culture
and I also want to make it really clear
I don't lead any of my companies you
know I'm I'm you're not the CEO of any
none of them they have their own
leadership team their own culture their
own chemistry their own electricity
their own values you know I may have
helped give a blueprint and an ethos but
I've always said if it's the same as the
way I left it you guys [ __ ] up
horribly right nothing should stay the
same you guys should should do this
thing on your own anybody quit when all
this came out no uh not yet not yet I
hope I hope nobody does you think
somebody will I I know I know I've made
some issues yeah I know I've created
some people who are upset yeah you know
I mean this is like a classic business
story right it's like there's a leader
whether they're actually running the
business or they're uh the founder or
whatever they do something sometimes
it's like super controversial they get
caught you know uh breaking the law or
doing something like that sometimes it's
bad business decisions sometimes they
say something about politics that has
nothing to do with the business but
people don't want to be associated with
that or whatever and then you got to
deal with like this like real life [ __ ]
right now you got to deal with yo I got
all these great people that work for me
we got these businesses that are going
[ __ ] turmoil inside right yeah you
know that that tugs up my heart amongst
you know like I would say I feel like
the the kids that I've let down that
that's the worst and then I think about
the people in my companies they move
their whole families here you know and
and this has been the hardest thing to
find are people people that are true
believers that are capable of doing you
know what what they're doing
um so man I really hope not
um and uh it's possible but yeah but
you're hoping not
um are you a billionaire no I'm not
[ __ ] I'm doing the [ __ ] math in
my head I think that you're a
billionaire
I'm not
all right well let's talk about it
because you do 100 million dollars in
Revenue listen you go eat donuts with
Schultz but I [ __ ] do math do 100
million dollars in Revenue right you got
50 employees you're probably doing 50
plus million dollars in profit 20 times
multiple on that like you probably are
close to a billionaire and I'm not
saying that in like a derogatory way and
people may get mad about it but like in
some way like if you are a billionaire
you've had a [ __ ] run
from an entrepreneurial standpoint
that's probably one of the better runs
in recent memory for people
and nobody thinks of you that way like
in some way literally interesting is uh
liver King is one of the best [ __ ]
Founders in the world hiding under
everyone's nose and people will say oh
he took steroids he's not a it doesn't
count or whatever right okay lay all the
critiques like you're a [ __ ]
billionaire first of all I'm not okay I
will disagree
I'm not really far
um and I hope I I've never want to
identify with that you know um
everything that I've done in business I
I did before the liver King launched the
liver King is brand new you know a lot
of people like oh liver King did all
this stuff he made all of his money you
know from this sort of deception I'm
saying throw that out I'm talking about
you as an entrepreneur forget liver King
forget the [ __ ] character all that
I'm talking about if you build
businesses that do 100 million dollars
in Revenue with the employee base
literally for you get off the internet
tomorrow
that is one of the most impressive
[ __ ] entrepreneurial stories thank
you you know the last decade I deserve
it I know I earned it you know and I
know that I earned it because again the
why in the world what we're doing and
this is why I welcome everyone to to
continue to do it I don't need more
money this is why more money is going
into doing a hundred of these businesses
because that's the only thing I care
about is advancing this message making
sure people acknowledge that how
desperately people are hurting and that
there's a simple solution to a better
life
um and but the only pushback I want to
give is just to remember you said
Liberty King aside right but liver
King's only been here for a year a year
and a couple of months right and so if
we had the same discussion about how
much money we're making a year and a
couple of months ago it's not that
different it's not that different
um liver King was strong my companies
were strong before liver King my
companies will continue to be strong
after liver King
you mentioned employees obvious there's
some things you got to work through
Partnerships things like that have other
people had issues as well or is this
more of uh your employees or somebody
that you trust they join because they're
True Believers things like that uh but
the partners are like all the right
questions our sales [ __ ] flying
hoping you weren't asking this one um I
do for a living of course I'm gonna ask
this [ __ ] yeah
um and you're like okay let me do the
math because he knows there's um one
partnership that uh might not withstand
this storm got it and it's more so they
just want to distance themselves from
controversy in general I'm assuming
you know what I don't want to talk about
any of the personal things related to
that but but there's one um I think
again I I know I did this yeah um and
that that's actually the hardest thing
on me is like [ __ ] all this stuff I did
could compromise this one incredible
it's not a company it's like it's a
living breathing thing where everybody
believes in what we're doing and once
again I got to be like I did that you
know like you know you you know when you
don't believe what you did was wrong man
you'll [ __ ] defend it you will die on
that Hill there's no dine on I can't
defend this thing are you reading my
text messages with my wife
I didn't do that right no but but in all
seriousness like I I do think that
um it's easy for people to point and say
oh you said X you did why whatever wrong
I think you've said it's wrong uh we get
sit here and beat that you know until
it's dead but uh there's also like real
life [ __ ] that's attached to this and
you know I usually see it from the
investor seat with companies I've
invested in where something goes wrong
and I'm on Twitter just like everybody
else I'm [ __ ] Doom scrolling usually
late at night right before I go to sleep
like I'm not supposed to and I'm reading
it and I'm like man these people are
just lay being into XYZ person or
company or whatever and I'm like they
got no clue the [ __ ] that that person's
dealing with right now because they got
their employees they got their investors
they got their own [ __ ] families like
you start thinking about this stuff and
it's an interesting perspective because
again I of course I know that yeah I'm
thinking nobody [ __ ] knows that and
nobody listen again I'm not asking for
sympathy but you're the first person
who's ever actually said that you know
the the layers deep that this goes my
wife and I said a long time ago I would
never go and I would never have a
partner ever again because in the dental
business we took on a partner and then
the mission that we wanted to drive
became convoluted you know when you can
no longer do exactly what you want to do
and it's not driven by your benevolent
principles now we got an issue because
now it gets driven by
an ulterior I'll just I'll just tell you
um because she wants to give people
liver bone marrow and egg yolk okay the
surgeon's like well hold on a second
you're gonna put me out of business you
know and he's a percent partner now too
hey this isn't okay I don't want you
telling people how to fix the root cause
and she's like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about like why would I not and
so after that she goes hey anybody you
interview you tell them in the interview
zero percent equity is on the table and
it never will be and so all my
interviews that's what I shared with
people well um I got softened up and
started to believe over time and I don't
think anything's wrong about it I I
think that uh I chose the best partner
in the world to do this with again this
is this is of my own creation
um and and so I I know you hear this all
the time but it's like you you want to
go fast go alone you want to go far go
together you can go fast and far with a
group of True Believers would you
believe that deeply and you got those
principles you've been really public
about your why this is the great thing
about like when you're really public
about your why in the world and you
could then only hire other True
Believers you can do incredible things
together so I did that I'm like oh you
know and and again there's so many
complexities that come into that that
come to play so there's a lot going
through my head right now you know and
again I listen I'm in the middle of it
I'm gonna deal with all of it you know
and and some people are like hey why
aren't you doing this I'm like listen do
you know how much is going on and what
I'm dealing with and how I'm trying you
know to to do the right thing but
there's a lot of moving pieces to it
you're right my last question for you is
uh Rogan after uh he was like yeah I
told you guys well whatever uh he said
uh he thinks the Rock's on steroids you
think rocks on steroids you know here's
the thing no I don't here's the thing
well did you think the rock is on
steroids I'm not picking any fights
anybody I don't think he should have
picked that fight either you know well
you know there's bad blood
well also people forget this uh
and this is my external perception
when uh the mob came for Rogan and I
think I told you when uh Andrew Schultz
was one of the first comedians to stand
up and say hey I know this dude you know
uh whatever uh The Rock
actually posted initially and said he's
not racist I know this guy or something
like that and then the mob came after
him oh and he basically backtracked he
was on [ __ ] roller skates
and he was like oh sorry I didn't see
the video or whatever he said and again
like I never judge anyone because I
don't know was he getting phone calls
from people with something going on did
he see something I didn't I have no clue
but there was almost like a retraction
and my guess is that uh that left uh a
bad taste and wow I didn't know that um
I mean there's a thing you know the the
rock what he's accomplished I think he's
gonna be president yeah he could be I I
I've been saying this for years now I
think the rock will be the president
United States but if Joe Rogan asked him
if he does steroids then that's gonna be
uh you know again I I you don't want to
pick a fight with the rock literally or
figuratively I mean this is this is not
the guy you know and so I'll just say I
think uh I think what The Rock has done
has been absolutely incredible yeah you
know and so is he on first of all I
don't think he's on steroids
um is he taking any hormone replacement
therapy I don't know what percentage of
American men do you think it's taken any
kind of hormone trt uh ghg stuff like
that like is it like one percent or do
you think it's like 20 I bet it's tiny I
bet it's about five percent and I think
the clinics know that most men because
because of the lifestyles that they lead
today because of the things that are
within their control like they're not
ancestral tenants
um they could recover this but a lot of
these clinics know we got such a tiny
fraction of the population that are
underserved I wish the hormone clinics
could also get behind this message it's
not real good for business you know for
the financial people so five or ten
million men
yeah I mean like just in the United
States you know you start doing five
percent depending on how you want to
calculate adults and like all these
different numbers or whatever I bet if
you tested though you have such a
significant amount that needed that
needed I shouldn't say that needed that
need to increase it find a way to
increase it do it either naturally or
yeah yeah I can't believe you tried to
make me make an enemy with a rock I love
the rock no no not not an enemy I mean
look it's uh it is uh it's interesting
that you said that you wouldn't [ __ ]
with them though because I seen Joe
Rogan do some roundhouse kicks
either all right yeah I still wouldn't
[ __ ] with broke you know it's like again
you'll never hear me say anything
negative about anybody like that's not
in me I'm not capable of that you hear
people say oh it takes two to tango well
guess what we won't be doing that I'm
not capable of that I know why you're
doing what you're doing you're hurting
man you're hurting and I can see you're
hurting you know and and the last thing
you need is a guy to engage to now
engage with that kind of thing you know
I still think what what Rogan does is
incredible I think with the rock does is
incredible I don't think anyone should
attempt to discount somebody's
achievements and go where they're going
by saying any of that kind of stuff if I
have the chance to meet either of them I
hope one day that I that I have the
chance of me with both of them and have
this kind to have a great conversation
because man like you put down the phone
and you have do what we're doing today
like doesn't that just fill you up yeah
I mean this is ancestral tenant nine
which is Bond put down the goddamn phone
and and just connect with people and to
be able to do that with giants like that
um the pbd said to me the other day who
do you have around you that's way better
than you and I said I got people around
me number one my wife number one my wife
but but now I'm like I'm looking at him
like well you now you and now you and I
hope to God one day I have Joe Rogan and
I hope to God one day I have the rock
you know and and again I I'm not saying
I I was hoping this opportunity would
come but it's come you know Derek has
helped me face my reality this is this
is it and it's also led to some
incredible opportunities for me to be as
transparent as we have been today about
it and for me to have some of these
incredible connections so I'm filled
with nothing but gratitude well I
appreciate you coming in and uh and
talking about it uh I think just sitting
down talking to people uh you learn so
much more about it and there's plenty of
people who are watching this and be like
nope I still hate this [ __ ] yeah
people like I love them right and
everything in between and so I'll keep
having the conversations and I I'm just
thankful for you to come here and uh I
appreciate and I wish you all the best
to you and uh and your incredible family
who for those that don't know there's
like 17 000 people in this room right
now uh who have been listening this
entire time but uh but I really
appreciate it and we'll definitely do it
again in the future oh yeah thank you